public hearing on House Bill 1292 and I
lumo thank you very much um Madam chair
and members of the committee committee
my name is David
luno i u uh represent the people who
live in hopkington and Bo and um and as
I always like to say uh as well as as
our statewide responsibilities people
that live in in communities all across
the granite state so what I'm what I'm
here to um to present to you this
morning is House Bill
1292 which is um relative to a very very
minor change uh to the state retire
uh health insurance plan and this was
brought to my
attention uh about a year ago was after
the bill filing period by uh by a
constituent uh who is a recent um uh uh
State employ retiree uh uh State uh
state employee and um and said that uh
said that he was hoping to be able to
keep his um their children on their plan
but um but the their children were I
think 24 25 years old and they they were
you know out of college now and and the
current
law with respect to um to eligibility of
children between the ages of 19 and 25
requires uh children to be a full-time
students so um not being able to to put
a bill in last year uh we did get a
little bit of research um help to uh
take a look at it what is the Affordable
Care what is federal law require and
federal law actually requires um uh
eliminating the um the the limitation on
um on children between the age of 1925
most plans can no longer require uh
those children to be full-time students
but those CH those um changes through
the Affordable Care Act at the federal
level don't apply to uh to the state
retiree plan and I don't remember all
the details why um why the state retiree
plan does not need the comply with that
Pro uh provision of the federal law but
um but all this um all this bill does on
lines uh three and four uh are just
removing the uh the limitation if
full-time students so um any fully
dependent minor children between the
ages of 19 and 25 could be carried uh on
a um uh on the family plan for a for a
um a retired state employee and I do
have some remarks
actually from our constituent uh with
respect to their situation and what uh
what prompted uh the request and uh if
you don't mind Madam chair I just if I
could just read it into the reckon I can
leave leave you with a copy or I can
leave us with a please summarize it and
leave us with a copy and we'll read it f
fantastic so um so our um uh our our
constituents uh both um both turned UH
60 years old in March of 20 23 they uh
they served the state as state employees
for more than 56 years of service um uh
their children are both recent graduates
recent graduates of University of New
Hampshire and they're early in their
careers and um and they're they're
wishing to be able to to keep them on uh
their um their their
uh their state retiree health insurance
policy until they turn uh 26 and it's
important to know and I think the um the
fiscal note also States this that the
premiums on these policies are fully
paid by the retie they're not paid for
by the state um uh that's that's one big
big point on this second big point on it
is is um we're bringing young kids young
people into the into the plan which
generally have a lower cost um um on
them than um uh than than than than many
others so um so we're hoping that um
that this committee would look favorably
on on on on House Bill 1292 and
recommend it ought to pass so thank you
very much I'm happy to take any
questions representative laus thank you
this is actually for uh the chair and
that is I don't see Mr Carlin here do
you know if anyone's here from the
retirement system because I have a
question for them this does not involve
the retirement system oh Department of
administrative
Services which is ready to testify but
hasn't given me op pink card yet uh will
administers this program I'll wait till
car is not involved I understand I'll
wait till she's
uh okay representative
manuti thank you madam chair thank you
representative luno for taking my
question so these youngsters are
currently on the retirees Health Plan
correct and they are asking to retain
them because they are not students
have graduated from student right so so
th this was you know as of a year ago so
I don't believe they're still on the
plan because they'd already graduated
from the University of New Hampshire um
uh but um but but I don't think our
constituents in this case are
necessarily the only constituents in the
state that may have um similar situation
where where either either they what
would want to bring um uh children onto
a family plan as opposed to just paying
paying out of pocket for just the um the
two-person plan they'd be paying out of
pocket for the family plan and um and I
think it's a it's a it's certainly a
nice benefit with uh with really no cost
to the U to the state uh to uh to to to
be able to um um you know help uh our
retirees who have committed um uh
significant service to all of our
needs thank you other
questions thank you very much
education okay and this is
uh thank you for the fin D
good morning Madam chair so again Joyce
Pitman I am the director of risk and
benefits with the Department of
administrative services and we run the
retiree health benefit
program um I marked support um what I'm
really here is to answer your questions
I assumed you'd have some from a retiree
Health Plan perspective um as far as the
language and the bill goes we don't have
any concerns with this um for a couple
reasons um the biggest one one is that
currently
today in order for dependents to be
covered under the retiree health benefit
program the retire is responsible for
100% of the cost of that plan so our
first concern is how is it being paid
for and it is being paid for by the
retiree um
we this is typically a lowcost
population to serve they're typically
younger they typically don't have a high
um cost Demand on the health care system
but um I think I heard a question being
asked as to why the federal government
why we exempt from that this is a
retiree health benefit program and the
Affordable Care Act refers to active
employee health benefit plans so the
retiree health program is outside of the
Affordable Care Act also referred to as
the
AA um so we are not required to cover
dependence however
um although indeterminable of how many
people will actually utilize the system
the retiree is paying the full cost of
that coverage so we have no reason to
oppose this bill um and it honestly from
an Administration standpoint some of
these I'll say dependents um go to
school after high school to college and
then so they are according to the bill
as it is the law today they're staying
on their parents' health benefit plan
until they're out of school they're no
longer full-time students so with By REM
moving that full-time student
requirement it's irrelevant if they go
to college or not once they're over the
age of 19 they remain on the plan until
through age 25 which does also align
with the Affordable Care Act so it just
allows the student to stay on longer so
to some the students have been on beyond
the age of 19 because they had
post-secondary education and some didn't
and they would remain on the plan I'm
happy to answer any questions thank you
representa so I just want to be sure
that if we were to um pass this bill and
turns into statute it would not have a
cost to the people of New Hampshire it
would be strictly a polic health
policies that are paid by the retirees
correct the retiree would be responsible
for the full cost what we call the
working rate which is the full cost of
the plan so correct that would be what I
can't guarantee is that um if you look
on a member by member basis remember
it's a larger risk pool right so um they
working rate or what they pay it's just
under $1,000 a month per um the way the
premium structure is is you pay for one
dependent so if you have three children
that are on the plan you pay for one um
and it's roughly about $1,000 doar a
month just just under I think it's
9883 per month um so whether or not that
exceeds that I'm not sure but it would
be applied to our regular calculation in
the
future so are you saying that if you
have three children you pay for one and
the other two are covered
okay that's true today that's that's
typical of family plans you get any
number of children included that's
correct representative leas thank you uh
so related
um I don't I don't remember if this plan
the state self-insuring or it's through
something else but my question is I mean
if it's self-insuring and somebody has
three children and it is going to cost
presumably the plan more for the other
two uh but if if it's part of some deal
or you move to a family plan then then
maybe the other two aren't going to cost
more so can you answer which it is
basically if there's if there's more
than one child is it really going to
cost the people in New Hampshire more
money according to our actuaries no it's
they do an Actuarial calculation to
figure out I think your question is if
$983,000 correct um the way the the math
works out the answer is no it it comes
out of the working rate so in a future
rate we would take whatever that cost
was and it would it could potentially
inflate the cost that retirees pay in
the future but I just want to remind
people that this is a very small
population and they're typically very
healthy so the chances of this doing
anything to the cost of the retiree
health benefit plan is really it's
indeterminable but it's minimal if
anything okay thank you yes represent
man py thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my
question so this is youngsters that are
just getting off or getting on their own
two feet and any time they can
transition out of their parents plan and
would
this impact dual enrollment or you
know um if whether or not it impacts
dual enrollment it depends on the health
benefit plan if they what the other
plans are typically when you stay on our
health benefit program it's primary um
if there is another plan they could look
at the coordination of benefits specific
to that plan um and as far as them being
youngsters so we're talking really when
they graduate from high school up
through age
25 um so I'll let you decide whether or
not they should be on their own it's
every parents you know family decision
but um yes it's a way of helping them
transition into when they transition off
of their parents and it allows it to
happen after they're age 25 if they have
an employer plan available to them or
something like that it does put it in
alignment with the Affordable Care Act
which is exactly what our active
employee population has today thank you
other
much is is there anyone else who wishes
1292 don't see anybody in that case I'm
hearing okay all right since we have a
few minutes uh we will go into executive
session and representative groa has a
motion yes I move a of pass on House
Bill
1292 is there a second second second by
represent of gold do you wish to speak
to your motion thank you Madame chair
this um Bill offers of the retirees the
same benefits as someone on the ACA and
since it doesn't since the retiree is
responsible 100% for the um fees I think
that this is a good benefit for New
Hampshire retirees who have families
represent
GS no further comment Jackie said at all
okay repres representative man py thank
thank you madam chair I think this gives
a good opportunity for young Workforce
to stay in the state and you know we are
facing that entry level so this will
give their youngsters a peace of mind to
have the medical benefit and then
explore opportunities in New Hampshire I
think it's a great benefit thank you
anyone else comments questions yeah I'd
like to say that increasing the size of
the pool in this health plan with
younger healthier people than your
average
problem okay
quorum yes we have 11 that is a quorum
so we can take a vote any further
comments all right those in
favor um the clerk can call the that's
it
forgive
me representative lakas
yes representative
Dolan clerk votes
yes representative Boyd yes
representative groa yes representative
Schmidt yes representative Shu
yes representative Gould yes yes
representative Smith yes representative
manager py
yes
110 oh and the chair I'm
sorry
yes my apologies I don't mind being
overlooked just getting over an illness
I
apologize all right so the the motion
passes 12 to Zer is there any objection
to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
it on consent
representative gr I'd appreciate a
committee report at your very earliest
right and we are in fact off until
10:30 we're going to be so cofed up
very fact
works
it is 10:30 and I'm opening the hearing
on on House Bill 1435 and I call the
conf thank you madam chair thank you
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is uh representative
Barbara com from belnap
7 so this bill was brought forward um
due to a constituent uh letting me know
that under current
law the that in a divorce div divorce
decree if one
spouse uh has a retirement system with
the state of New Hampshire and in that
decree uh they get to get a portion of
that retirement
system um you know no
problems however I when talking with
this
constituent um she was nearing Social
Security age
and uh was
collecting uh what was in the divorce
decree uh because the spous had retired
a monthly uh stipend I guess is what
I'll call it and um So based on the
amount uh she filed for Social Security
was
retiring and lo and behold the former
spouse says you know what yeah I'm going
to go back to work soon so now you no
stien
and under New Hampshire law if somebody
goes back to work even if the spouse is
already collecting the funds and relying
away because apparently in the system
when some one goes back to work their
retirement benefits stop and they keep
system this has created a hardship and
in speaking with this person they had
also let me know that uh the
person that they dealt with in regards
to this has had told her that she had
other people calling up crying because
they would lose their houses over
this now I'm not
asking for
for people that are do the money that
haven't started collecting to get the
money but if the spouse retires and then
decides to go back to work and in this
case we believe it was retaliation based
on her comments I don't know if that's
true or not I'm just relaying the
story um Force this person back to work
full-time they were already working but
then also put them over the limit to
make ends meets so now that their ta
Social Security is now
taxed so it was kind of like a double
whammy because they collected early so
that they couldn't there's a certain age
where you can only make so much money
under the social security
system and so I brought this forward I
spoke with OS he said the commissioner
said that this was a rare rare occasion
that this happens um according to s um
when they did the
research or legislative research I
should say
so I put in this simple line that says
that if you've already started
collecting because your spouse had
retired the payments don't cease to the
other spouse if it's in the divorce
decree that's it it's not saying
everyone gets to start collecting or
anything like that it's only if it's
already started that it can't stop
because if it's hurting one person it's
hurting others as we know how things go
but people don't know where to go and
and how to come forward I just happen to
be in a place where someone told me
about this and I felt that this really
needed to be addressed and I'm open for
questions thank you representative
Smith if a spouse goes back to work C
can you hear I'm not sure this is close
to enough I'm sorry
um you just turned it
off Hightech I can't do
it okay if a if a spouse goes back to
work then he's or she is going to earn
more money that will increase the
retirement for that person will it also
increase the retirement for the spouse
thank you for the question uh
Representative no it's a set amount in a
decrease so that amount does not
increase okay so the person receiving it
at originally will get only that amount
correct thank you thank you okay it also
depends on this former spouse retiring a
second time which may be
delayed okay anyone else question
representative
Shu thank you madam chair
um P this a little closer um would it
not be true that a person in such a
circumstance would uh be eligible to go
to court
to pursue having support from their
former
spouse uh thank you for the question um
I did ask that question but it's
costly and so it's a hardship uh for
funds but they could yes represent
BR I'm under the impression that if you
have to go to court and you don't have
the funds the court can provides a
service for you is that not
true um thank you for the question I'm
really not familiar with all of this
it's uh however um the amount of time
and then the time out of work because
they did have to go back to work
and wasn't uh they didn't seem to think
that it was the right thing to do and uh
they just decided uh that they would cut
their losses at this time that the
requirement
for
um representation is for criminal
actions if you're suing in family court
you don't you're not
entitled uh thank you for that
clarification because they did say it
was going to be quite costly for
them okay anyone else represent man py
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um this is very
similar to child or alimony kind of
thing so you go back to the court or go
back to the settlement if there is a
change in life status isn't it so that
would warrant if there is a change in
the Life
status uh you would go back to change it
well thank you for the question and
looking at this but this here in this
particular case um that I'm aware of is
it was kind of an I gotta moment it was
an ret they said you know what we're
going to go back to work even though
they were at retirement age and
collecting
retirement because they wanted to harm
this
person all
right
other questions thank you very much
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee Mr Carlin Let's Get the
facts out and then hear from
representative
Pearson thank you madam chair for the
record Marty Carlin representing the New
Hampshire retirement system uh the uh
nhrs has not currently taken a position
on this bill although we do have some
some uh legal concerns with existing
statute and the Internal Revenue code uh
regarding the application of the the
bill um historically you know as under
current law nhrs permits shared payment
qualified Domestic Relations orders
referes quadros this is a divorce decree
or settlement uh adjudicated in court
and we apply that court order to any
distribution of retirement benefits or
other assets um as we don't you know we
we just we just qualify it but the
courts make those decisions on who gets
what and so those can be a you know a
flat amount of a pension they could be a
percentage of a total pension there
there's different very permutations on
that but essentially what that's what
the law allows that to happen is for
that that member's benefit to a portion
of it to be paid to someone else because
of a you know a divorce decree or
divorce settlement however that that
doesn't make the the quadro recipient a
member so our concern under curent La is
if the member um you know the the
they're deriving a benefit as a portion
of a retired member's benefit and if the
retired member isn't is is no longer
retired there's no benefit to receive a
portion of um you know we would be
essentially having to pay a benefit to a
non-member which is which is not allowed
it's you know under very statutes and
yeah all right that's a very interesting
position representative M py and then
representative G thank you madam
chair it was very you explained it very
clearly in uh interesting perspective
but how would this impact your whole New
Hampshire retirement system by tweaking
this is a non-member getting the benefit
access to the benefit it it's it's um
you know there there is a both in in the
Internal Revenue code and in in um uh
statute and in the Constitution there's
a clause you know for the um exclusive
benefit of members and beneficiary so
providing any um any relief to a
non-member would arguably someone could
say that's not violates the exclusive
purpose rule because it's not a member I
mean the dollar amount certainly with
the size of the benefits we pay isn't
the issue it's it's the question of
opening the door to taking trust fund
assets which were you know member and
employer contributions and investment
income and dispersing that to to someone
who's not was not a plan member you know
for for a benefit I mean it's different
if a retire a member retires and can
leave a survivorship option to a
beneficiary there's a whole legal
pathway for that and certainly
non-members get money from us but this
is an issue that may be more the perview
of of civil court
to this in this unfortunate situation
facing representative scho thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question my question
is if
um the current statute and and procedure
is a former a retired employee and their
beneficiaries wouldn't a former wife
that a court has declared entitled to a
portion of it fit under a beneficiary
category um well if if you're you can be
nominated as a beneficiary you know for
an active member if there's a death Ben
benefit payable to whoever the nominated
beneficiary or beneficiaries are you
know but in this case it's it's a
beneficiary for pension that no longer
exists because the person was restored
to service so so there's no base benefit
from which to draw a portion of okay and
follow so in in the event the court has
ordered a flat fee you don't have to
calculate anything um can you tell us
how
many circumstances you currently have
where you're paying these um exp spouses
based on court orders uh we we have
approximately
650 Quadro benefits paid out of uh more
than 43,000 benefit recipients so um you
know so that that's that's
the that's the universe and and you know
they're you know again there's they can
negotiate or the court could order
different distributions and different
things some of them um you know but but
you know we apply them as they come in
okay and one last follow up thank you
madam chair and so
um do I remember my
followup and how many
and I'm sorry I forgot my followup any
other
questions so if if I understand your
testimony you're saying
that with a court order you'll pay
whatever is
required if the the person returns to
work and rejoins the system there is no
pension to be split and the EXP spouse
may have no other relationship with the
pension
system when that re person retires again
which I presume will happen does the the
court ORD still apply it it should
unless it was changed because you know
it it governs when when the the
distribution of a pension benefits so
when the person you know retires or or
retires again okay thank you that's
important to know yes representative
gold I collected my thoughts thank you
and wrote them down this time okay so
when the retiree goes back to work they
are now there's no um pension active
pension benefit in place because they
are no longer withdrawing money out of
the system and instead they're adding
money into the system correct correct so
my question goes to um something
representative leus usually ask which is
cost to the system or the taxpayers or
the workers and that would be wouldn't
this uh fiscally be a benefit in a way
that the retirees gone back but this
person's still getting a set fee that
they previously
got is that am I making sense to you I I
think so and I'll I'll try to answer it
and if if I'm going down the wrong path
but I mean you know as essentially you
know the you know the members have
always been allowed to return to
full-time employment after retirement an
opportunity comes along or or whatever
reason uh there's a job that they feel
is a good fit for them and you know in
that case you know the pension stops and
they're they're acre additional service
they're contributing more money so
ultimately you know their pension is is
going to be probably larger than it was
um you know because um you know of the
additional time they're they're putting
in so when they collect the benefit
there's more it's it's somewhat neutral
you know cost-wise to the system for
that because if if it was a full-time
permanent position somebody would be
working in it we'd still be getting
contributions in the you yeah so um you
know but but the the the carve out of
the paying an allowance to someone else
I mean that that's just money coming out
there's no fiscal advantage to that you
know even if even if it was legally
permissible you know it's just it's
additional money I mean it um again I I
understand not firsthand but I
understand court cases can cost the
individuals a lot of money but if the
person is working full-time and making
more of a salary there may be an
opportunity for the the spouse
to get a piece of that um to to make be
made whole through that
questions get represent black thank you
so um given that this doesn't allocate
any money to the retirement system for
the cost which I guess would be hard
because it's not defined but anything
you did did have to pay out under this
wouldn't that in effect um you know
after the readjustments increase the uh
unfunded acred liability payments that
all the Employers in the state have to
pay even if it's by a little bit but
that's where the money would come from
yeah I mean it would be in the you know
farther out in the rounding if it if
it's a oneoff but it may not be we've
got several hundred of these I mean I
certainly relationships end amicably or
otherwise and and you know there there
could be other individuals affected by
this and if we're paying benefits to
nonmembers or retirees you know when it
gets larger then you know the the plan
qualification issue comes up again as
well as the funding issue okay thank you
other
questions thank you very much
representative
Pearson got you
okay good morning the record
Representative Steve Pearson Rockingham
District 13 which is encompasses
Dairy um I am not in favor or oppose to
this bill I wanted to especially hear
what Mr Carlin had to
say I want to bring up two
points uh the first point is that in the
state of New Hampshire a spouse can
commit infidelity in this case and still
especially in group two walk away with
50% which I which I have a problem with
we are a state that does not recognize
that as some other states do so just
keep in mind
that through that's a situation that can
occur this the second thing here is that
I'm concerned about where we're going
down the road here in the sense
that if if we start to dictate
how things
function whether you know in in in an
Essence we're not removing the ability
of the employ to go back to work but
we're certainly tying something to it my
concern is that later on we're going to
get to the point where a spouse or a
court will tell someone they can't
retire or they have to retire to provide
a former spouse of benefit because they
don't want to wait so that's that's the
problem here is that I'm concerned about
where we're going with
this uh based on the fact that we've
we've had a system in place for quite a
long time so the conditions of group one
and group two are different when it
comes to divorce so just please keep
that in mind as well whereas in group
one you're going to have a a settlement
you're going to have an agreement
whereas in group two the spouse
automatically gets 50% regardless of
what that spouse
did so again like I said I'm not
necessarily for or against I have
concerns now based on what Mr Carlin
said about the constitutionality of this
based on the way the retirement system
is mentioned in our constitution in
article
36 and in the general operation of the
system in relationship to the IRS rules
I think that that really requires some
more deep look here to make sure that
this is even possible regardless of
whether or not the house wants to do
this or
not so that that's where I am with that
I'm I'm let's just call it
caution thank you R Schmid has a
question thank you madam
chair so the the question I have it was
already slightly addressed but the in
reality uh the the system is already
dealing with I I believe Mr Carlin said
something like 600 I believe it 600 out
of
43,000 yeah for round numbers so that we
we already have established a at least a
pattern of paying out and I think we
have to try to adhere to
the if it's it's a oneof in every case
that's 600 one
offs that's not a system anymore so
could you address that issue I'll try
Peter because I'm not entirely sure what
you just asked
me thank you representative Pearson I
think we can all agree on that I I'm not
I'm not entirely sure as far as does 650
events equal 650 individual one-off
cases again I I'm not sure because I we
would need to see the breakdown between
group one and group two with that
because the conditions for the two
groups as far as divorce are are not
equal okay other
questions all right thank you very much
testimony does anyone else wish to
1435 okay then I will close the public
hearing and go into executive session
representative Shu you have a
motion Madam
[Music]
chair uh yes I would like to move in
expedient to legislate on House Bill
1435 is there a
second r on leus second is that LE you
wish to speak to your
motion yes it it appears uh that this
would violate um probably IRS rules and
State um retirement system would be
hardpressed to come up with a logistical
reason to make such
payments represent leus um thank you I
agree the only other comment I would
have is that I mean if this is more than
an extremely rare Circumstance the
family courts could take you know put
some provision in the original agreement
as to what should happen in the case
that the pension goes away I mean that I
don't think that I don't know that that
would take statute it could just be
practiced at court but I believe the
family court can make whatever
stipulations they like right so I mean
if this is a big enough problem then
they could do something like that if
they chose or you know be good if we
could do something to make civil court
cheaper but anyway uh I agree with the
schm uh I I agree with the the motion uh
and the thing is that the courts are
where you do
individual dispositions based on
individual circumstances rather than
having the statutes having to dance all
over the place I think is unwise so as
much as I can feel that uh it's an
unfortunate circumstance it's not for
the legislature to deal with it's for
the courts to deal with in my
opinion thank you anyone else comments
questions
representative Dolan thank you madam
chair I we received testimony that this
particular case the the uh male
individual probably want wanted to harm
the
constituent um through this action I
don't while I don't disbelieve the
testimony we received I don't think we
we certainly don't have an indep
independent evidence of that um and also
in this case the
individual uh confessed that they didn't
have the indiv the ability to pay for
the legal cost to take the individual
court so if you if you think of the
reverse of that if this were to pass
then those who
can bear the cost of going to court
would no longer have to bear those costs
they would benefit from from this uh
change so with that in mind I I I agree
with the the inexpedient to legislation
anyone else representative gold I just
had a question on um the statement that
representative Shu made regarding uh
breaking IRS rules I didn't hear that
testimony Mr I miss it commented on the
fact that the IRS rules for I believe
forbid making payments to someone who is
not either a member or a beneficiary is
that correct Mr Carla yeah okay thank
you
yeah and the connection to the system is
broken once the pension ends could I
please ask everybody to put their mouth
near the microphone because it is
incredibly difficult to hear please
thank you
okay yes representative
Schmidt he was going to
appreciate
are there any other relevant
comments all right seeing none the
motion is inexpedient to legislate on
repes by representative sht the clerk
can call the
role representative lakas yes
representative
Dolan uh clerk votes yes representative
Boyd yes representative grov
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative sht yes representative
Gould Madam chair I have a techn a
processed question if I abstain does
that mean you don't have a
Yes representative Smith yes
representative Manti yes and the chair
nay
introducing
okay all right that's 11 motion passes
110 is there any objection to
consent I not seeing none I will put
this on consent representative Shu it um
at your very earliest convenience
like today so how do we go from 12 to
Z someone stepped
out Madam chair ratification on
1292 I think it is 11 to0 no it was 12
to0 who has stepped out nobody's stepped
out no no 11 11 yeah oh you said 12
after I said 12 but apparently I was
toer yeah all right thank you sorry I
was having a senior moment all right we
have um it's 11 just about 11 time for
the next
hearing we're out of executive
session and on house bills
1352 representative groda is introducing
it thank you madam chair my name is
representative Jackie groa I represent
the towns of Rockingham of Ryan
Greenland and District 24 I'm here to
introduce House Bill 1352 for the prime
sponsor relative to firefighting person
personal protective equipment and with
that I ask you please to call Mr will
who can give you more details about the
Bill thank you
okay representative R oh not Mr R sorry
excuse
here
good morning Madam chair thank you for
the promotion I appreciate
that and good morning uh members of the
committee for the record my name is
Brian will I'm the president of the
professional firefighters of New
Hampshire uh we represent approximately
2,000 active and retired firefighters uh
throughout the
state I would like to thank
representative groda for introducing uh
House Bill
1352 uh this was a bill that uh we
requested um bipartisan sponsor ship on
uh based um on a few factors this bill
does a few things here um and I'll just
walk you through it uh first you'll see
on uh line 10 of page one firefighting
station wear has been defined um nowhere
in current statute to my knowledge uh is
this something that is defined uh
station wear just for everyone's um own
knowledge is essentially your uniforms
that you wear uh day in and day out to
the fire station um
and you conduct all of your duties in uh
and then when you were responding to um
what we call an idlh or a situation that
is immediately dangerous to life and
health that we then Dawn our firefighter
turnout protective equipment uh over the
top of those uniforms so um we have
defined what firefighter station wear is
uh if you look further down the page um
the area of uh line
26 um it clarifies some language that is
in there currently
with firefighter PPE I think it's
wellknown fact now that our personal
protective equipment comes manufactured
with past chemicals actually built into
it um it is in current law now that if
that is the case the manufacturer is
required to um Supply a letter stating
that the firefighter PPE can contains
past chemicals uh and that letter is to
be maintained in the employees personnel
file um what we're trying to do here is
to put additional pressure on the
manufacturing companies um to do
something about our turnout gear that
has p in it um things are not happening
at the rate that we'd like to see them
happen at um so we want them to uh
identify whether firefighters turnout
gear does or does not contain pfast
chemicals now What's significant about
this is there is currently no turnout
gear on the market that has been tested
scientifically and proven to not have
pfast chemicals in it however there are
manufacturing companies that are
claiming that their gear does not
contain pfast
chemicals what we're attempting to do
here is to get the manufacturer on
record to State whether the gear does or
does not have those those chemicals in
it further we'd like uh a letter uh not
only to be placed in the employees
personnel file um but to ensure that
there is proper documentation of this
the employee should also be provided the
same documentation directly um and and
we do know for reference there are fire
departments um not not intentionally
doing so but that are unaware that this
law currently exists on the books and we
have found that um some fire departments
are not in fact supplying these letters
in Personnel files so we want to it's an
additional layer of safety that we want
to uh ensure that we take care
of uh on page two and line nine uh there
begins another piece to this because of
the uh manufacturing industry and the
the pressures that we're putting on them
on an international level they are
researching
uh Alternatives that do not have these
chemicals in them um it's we would
contest that when these new generation
of firefighter turnout gear becomes um
becomes available that our fire
departments should give preference to
those uh those
specific uh articles that do not have
the pasas in
them um most departments um if not all I
believe all should have in place a
routine Gear replacement program
firefighter turnout gear has a shelf
life of 10 years um so if I were to get
a set of turnout gear tomorrow uh in
theory it needs to be replaced within 10
years the request here is to make it
such that if there is a new generation
of turnout gear uh that is a safe
alternative that becomes available um
during a Department's normal replacement
plan that it would be given preference
uh over the gear that is known to have
uh be manufactured with intentionally
added pfast
chemicals
um until such time and and you look in
subsection B that a safe alternative is
provided to the employee um we would ask
that fire departments shall have in
place a policy that limits unnecessary
exposure to firefighting turnout gear um
this is not to say that the normal
day-to-day duties uh we should not be
wearing our turnout gear um when it's
most appropriate to do so we acknowledge
the fact that this is still the safest
mechanism to protect our firefighters
from an idlh environment uh what we're
asking is that we limit exposures uh for
instance firefighters out
um standing by of a wire down or a power
line down um potentially wearing their
turnout gear because it's cold outside
or directing traffic in the snow with
their with their cat on because it's
cold outside or raining um or uh
training in it that is not necessary for
your job function um some fire
departments have uh allowed firefighters
to Dawn their firefighter PPE and go on
um a rower or a treadmill for exercise
um there is training that needs we need
to on this gear 4 there is training that
we don't um that is up to the fire chief
um the management to determine what is
necessary and what is not so we would
ask that there is there exists a policy
in every Department uh that that makes
that
determination and uh by January 1st uh
2025 fire department shall not have uh
as an option for wearing a firefighter
station wear that contains intentionally
added pasas and I listed a few there um
this is from a study from the
International Association of
firefighters where they determined that
some of those uniforms that I spoke
about earlier actually also contain fire
resistive chemicals uh that are
carcinogenic in nature and giving our
firefighters cancer um there are
alternatives on the market in fact we
used to wear them many many years ago
and these would just be your organically
treated Cottons that do not have
intentionally added chemicals
um the the tradeoff that some might
contest is that okay it doesn't protect
you in in superheated environments and I
think that that's
fair um but I can tell you uh in this
day and age the the number of fires that
our firefighters are exposed to uh have
decreased which is good on all fronts um
but we're still wearing this these
uniforms every single day to do every
single function um so we need to
identify the risk vers benefit there um
so that sums up um all of the pieces of
this bill it's it's somewhat
comprehensive and I recognize that um I
would like to address uh on page two
line
10 um if I could offer and I've spoke
with representative goalie Who's the
prime sponsor in this um a small
Amendment uh on page 10 to strike the
words shall be required
to and replace it with the word
should and the reason for this is uh in
conversations with some other
stakeholders um there was a a little bit
of angst as to whether or not um this
created an unfunded mandate and or uh
put fire departments in a position uh
where we were asking them to do
something that was
unreasonable um meaning if there's a
new uh generation of turnout gear that
becomes available able that does not
have past chemicals in it but it lacks
in other function functionality that we
need for the job or the cost is
extravagant or um the availability is
too scarce based on every fire
department and the nation trying to get
at it um we don't want our firefighters
walking around without some sort of
turnout gear as I mentioned we still
acknowledge the fact that it is the
safest um mechanis M that we have in
place to protect our members um from an
ideal AG so I would ask that that uh
Amendment be submitted so that um we
just uh we would we would deal with
those um concerns and I'd be happy to
answer any questions you might have
thank you representative gold thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question my question is um having heard
this testimony when we were addressing
increased cancer screening because of
the pat in the in the gear turnout gear
last year and
having so much of my family be
firefighters and and in um
Administration in the firefighting
Fields um it was shocking how many did
not understand the risks that were in
the P um and I did quite a bit of
research so my question to you is um
there seems to be a lot of very
promising research on wool as being um
part of the solution in moving forward
in sec second generation firefighting
have you are you aware of that and do
you think that um the people making
these decisions that we're talking about
and by the way I support the should
instead of sh be um language change but
are you aware whether this uh how how
well people are staying on top of the
trends and what's coming out for
Alternatives thank you for your question
representative um I'm extremely
confident our uh we're a state affiliate
of the International Association of
firefighters uh which represents 343,000
firefighters across the United States
and Canada and this is by and large
their number one um issue that they're
working towards right now um this has
become a federal uh fight and New
Hampshire um by our cancer legislation
that we passed last year um with the
presumptive law uh in the cancer
legislation that we saw um supported in
a senate committee a couple of weeks ago
New Hampshire is on the map as one of
the one of if not the most Progressive
state in the nation that's paying
attention to this issue um so we are
paying attention to the the research um
we are paying attention to the data that
comes out of the research um and the
International Association of
firefighters has run um tests on on both
firefighter station Weare and
firefighting turnout gear um and they're
working with the manufacturers to
determine what the best alternative is
um it it's it's a little bit it get the
M the waters get a little bit muddied
because there are three layers to
firefighter turnout gear and some layers
with some manufacturers have p in it
whereas others don't but those others
have pasas in their other layers so
we're trying to find the ability to mix
and match here thank you thank you
represent Dolan and then
Shu thank you madam chair um and thank
you for taking my question
uh while I'm very concerned about the
safety of our
firefighters um and I I do acknowledge
the the amendment uh that you're
proposing uh what I'm concerned about is
during this period of of a
transition from the old G old gear to
the new gear with without P Fass in it
uh is there any protection from
municipalities from a legal standpoint
that they don't get if they if they turn
out their firefighters for incident
especially the
uh more poorly funded departments in the
state or maybe volunteer forces or
whatever if they turn them out with with
past contaminated equipment during this
trans because they haven't a chance to
upgrade what protects them from legal
liability that that they have introduced
Pas chemicals to these individuals is
there any
protection thank you representative um
my short answer would be I don't know
the answer to that um but I would
say that right now as it stands every
Fire Department in the state of New
Hampshire is acknowledging the fact that
they're putting their firefighters in
danger and at risk by putting them
mandator putting them in firefighter
turnout gear that is Laden with pfast
chemicals in all three layers um that is
an acknowledgement now and what I can
tell you from um an international
perspective is that there are um they
have watched this
they we're all concerned about the same
things and the idea here is not to um
get anybody uh to to violate uh a state
law but also we're trying to be
reasonable in the language here to
acknowledge the fact that this may not
happen
overnight and we want to try and work
with the employers to get it done as
soon as possible as a as a follow thank
you as a follow-up question followup uh
would you object to an amendment that
that limited the liability to the local
municipality for this issue while we're
in
transition representative Dolan I think
the requirement the personal protective
equipment replacement program
implies that there will be a
transition um but if you can think of
some good good legal language well that
might make some
sense representative I could tell you I
I had a conversation yesterday um about
something similar and we were talking
about the gear rep replacement program
um that's a replacement program that
Although our shelf life has 10-year
lifespan um our Administration Within
our fire departments determines what our
Gear replacement program will be um that
happens now it that wouldn't be a change
so maybe the Gear replacement program is
five years maybe it's 10 um but there
would be some ability for the chief the
the department and whatever elected body
they have that oversees a a budgetary
need or whatever would be able to make
the decision uh as to how to best
implement the program thank you sh it
thank you madam chair um I call your
attention to the bottom of the first
page lines 29 and 30 the added language
and a copy of the same shall be provided
directly to the employee and I see a
comma there I don't mean this to be
nitpicky I'm serious uh was there
supposed to be more language after that
that inadvertently got deleted needed or
was is that Comma just a typo I believe
it's just a typo thank you okay a period
after that sentence representative laus
thank you um so I'm uh I'm pretty
sensitive to the um unfunded mandate
thing so uh I appreciate the amendment
you suggested and certainly I couldn't
have supported that without that but I
have a related question so starting line
18 um it requires that um you know they
must not be provided the option of
having station wear that has some of
this stuff in it and the question is um
you know in general I know may vary but
in general it's the station we paid by
the employer or the employee and if by
the uh employer you know how much is
this going to cost because this has to
be in place as I understand it by the
beginning of next year and if it's you
know most of the the wear out there has
these things and all of it's going to
have to be replaced this year uh at
least as I read this and so how much is
that going to be because that could be
seen I think as an unfunded mandate to
the uh municipalities thank you
representative um first and foremost
there is uh under current state law um
and and I can't cite it for you now but
I can certainly try and find it for you
um a law which states the employer must
provide the uh uniforms if they require
uniforms to be worn um what this does
and it's kind of in the fine print here
shall not provide as an option uh the
wearing of so essentially what happens
right now in our fire departments is a
firefighter gets a in most cases a
uniform allowance right that may be $500
a year and they're told you need to have
navy blue pants uh uniform shirts
whatever else black boots all these
things um and in most cases they are
provided a list of optional items if you
want to buy a winter hat if you want to
buy a baseball hat if you want to buy a
sweatshirt you can do these um as as an
option what we're saying here is the
fire
resistive uh clothing will not be
allowed as an option for the employee to
purchase so um it would be incumbent
upon the
employee to make sure that when they're
using their uniform allowance they're
purchasing the right items oh followup
follow up okay so as I understand what
you just said that option is for the
option of what they can purchase when
they replace their existing uh equip you
know clothing uniforms and they're going
to buy new ones however this says it
shall not provide as an option the
wearing of firefighter station we which
to me says that starting January 1st
they would be prohibited from wearing
any existing uniforms they have if they
contain any of these things which means
they would need to be replaced the ones
that have that stuff in them would all
need to be replaced before the end of
the year um and so that is a uh um you
know Mandate of uh replacing equipment
that presumably would not need to be
replaced that early at least not for
everybody thank you I me is that my
understanding correct or yeah your
understanding is correct I I would say
if it
um if the the date needs to be amended
we can amend the date I would be happy
to do that that would mean that um to my
knowledge there's no Department that
doesn't provide the uniform allowance on
an annual basis um so that the passage
of this law in theory one year after
that you would be getting a new a new
uniform allowance anyhow all right thank
you okay yes
represent thank you madam chair just to
follow up on that I think I'm hearing
two different things to if I understand
correctly Tony asked you if starting on
line 18 this bill would mandate that
every Department replace all turnout
Gear with non-p no this is not about
turnout GE all right so the I know what
it that he's that you're talking about
um the
$500 uniform allowance that employees
get so is that what your you were
questioning is that they not I
understood this was the station wear or
not the turnout gear and that's what I
was asking about all right okay thank
thanks okay repres
man thank you madam s thank you for
taking my question so this applies to
both um fire departments in a city or a
volunteer firefighter correct anybody
who's a firefighter in the state abides
by this and do the volunteer
firefighters also get allowance to buy
the gear I am unaware of how the
volunteer
uh
firefighters operate um but I'll to my
knowledge most most volunteer fire
departments would not get a uniform
allowance but they would then be
provided with a a shirt um most don't
have in theory a full uniform that they
wear this would be for the professional
departments the full-time
departments um by representative Pearson
is volunteering to explain how VI
volunteer fire departments deal with
with this so if you could hold your
question on that he'd since Mr real
doesn't know the answer represent laus
hopefully a brief uh thing related to
that so on the section starting on page
two line 18 if it was changed to say
something like um you know starting
January 1 2025 they they shouldn't uh
provide a purchase option for new
clothing uh that contain that stuff and
then maybe at a later date um let's say
2026 beginning of
2026 um you know they they shouldn't
require them to wear it or permit them
to wear clothing I would be supportive
and and supportive followup real quick
so do you know follow okay thank you um
so is the cycle of replacement of this
station wear typically like yearly I
mean they get the if they get the
allotment yearly do they typically turn
over that stuff every year yeah um
there's really nothing um proprietary
about station wear it's you know it's
it's clothes that you could go buy at
any department store these are just
treated with with past chemicals that's
that's the piece that we're trying to
avoid um so if you think of it uh no
different than a suit you may wear here
every day uh at some point you're going
to have to turn over those articles and
buy new ones so um yes I will tell you
uh in every fire department that I'm
aware of across the state people are
replacing their uniforms on an annual
basis okay thank you other
questions all right thank you very
Pearson I thank you Edna good morning
for the record Representative Steve
Pearson Rockingham District 13 which
encompasses
dairy uh as many of you know I've I've
been in the fire service for 27 years
both in the paid career side of things
and also in the volunteer side so I'm
going to I can address a couple of
things and and um president will from
the pffnh uh gave you a great
explanation of a a holistic thing I can
provide you a practical day-to-day
reality for me and just to just to give
the
my
perspective um from my own circumstances
as far far as the volunteer fire service
it depends on if the volunteer
department requires something specific
the second they do now under because
they're still employees under the labor
rules they are now required to have
their uniforms either provided or
clothing allowance given to them if the
volunteer fire department does not have
any sort of requirement as to what they
wear which generally they don't because
if you're cruising around in a pickup
truck and the pedra goes off you're not
going to rush home to change your
clothes right so in those cases you're
you could be in jeans and a t-shirt or I
have fought fire in a suit well part of
a suit before so between my the two
weeks of my grandfather so you never you
never know what you're going to be
wearing so that that's the
differentiation there representative
leus is is it has to do with it is the
requirement of the of the specific
Department uh a lot of departments now
especially in Rockingham County and
Hillsboro County have day Crews where
they're hiring pums or they have some
folks that might work a shift or two a
week in the cases of those folks require
having a required uniform that
absolutely is falls under labor labor
standard now
the it the the situation and I'll give
you an example of my my own Universe in
for the the first 15 or so years of my
career we wore Hanes cotton t-shirts
that had silk screen on them hes cotton
t-shirts are not treated with Pas at all
they're um they're they're no different
than any other t-shirt you can buy from
any retailer they just would they would
just have silk screen or embroidery put
on them and then we got a little bit
more formal and went to a type of a
collared shirt that was made by a
company called 511 that
provides uniform type shirts to lawn
emergency services and others
unfortunately around a year and a half
and ago we learned that the
511 products contain pasas I am still
required to wear that shirt despite the
fact that for a very long time we wore
hannes cotton t-shirts or Fruit of the
Loom cotton
t-shirts so as far as the and we're
talking station wear here as far as the
ability to acquire station wear that
would get us out of this pest business
it's absolutely no burden of any kind it
that Hanes cotton T-shirts they make by
the Millions though that's that's not
difficult at all as far as and it's no
different than the pants I think that
the main thing of course when you use
the word uniform is is the definition of
uniform that all of your folks are the
same so having having been in the in
this
business prior to having a little bit
more simple uniform but certainly a
pfast free one that's not an issue now
as far as clothing allowances go one of
the things that my department has is a
no excuse Poli policy for uniforms that
are unsightly right because we have a
clothing allowance in my particular case
in the city of Manchester it's every 6
months so if you have a collar that's
frayed or you have a button that's
missing there's no excuse for you right
because you get a clothing allowance and
you are expected to have a proper
uniform so in this case this enables or
requires I guess kind of a little bit of
both the sense that with a with a dated
Line in the Sand we're going to do this
now now whereas that is a
manufacturing issue for turnout gear it
is absolutely not an issue for station
wear and I and I hope that the committee
doesn't confuse the two because the
circumstances under both of them are
very very different
so as you know as far as far as you're
concerned about the unfunded
mandate I I don't I don't know that I
view this in that sense where their
municipalities are already providing the
funding to do this they're just saying
hey buy X versus y we're we're not going
to give you more money we're not
changing our clothing allowance policies
we're just saying we're this is what
we're going to go to and we expect as
you receive your clothing allowance that
you will comply with with this
change black you have a followup yeah
thank you I mean do you see I understand
that uh but do you see the issue that on
line 18 on page two it requires two
things to occur on the same day one is
they can't provide as an option you know
the uh I guess to purchase although it
doesn't say this the clothing that
doesn't have the p in it um but also um
they're not allowed to wear it so it's
like the option to buy the non-past
stuff is provided on the same day you're
not allowed to wear the other stuff sure
so I I I don't oppose any of this it
just seems like that's a problem that
needs to be fixed in the bill I sure I
think I should mention here that this
bill is going to go to subcommittee to
correct the one change and look at this
other section to make sure that it's not
it doesn't have unintended consequences
okay that was my I get I get what you're
saying with the with the with that not
having much of a difference I I can also
tell you that um you know for for this
bill to go through the process and be
successful you you will have um fire
departments immediately start the
process of of how we're going to how
they're they're going to be addressing
this it's they're not going to wait till
January of 2025 to go oh wait now we
have to thank I mean the bill says what
it says sure but thanks yes but I think
we with at least two sections where we
need some word smithing it it needs to
go to subcommittee to get that
subcommittee
G thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question so you kind of
clarified the distinction between
volunteer firefighters and paid
firefighter Department um I just to
further that to clarify that um so the
volunteer firefighter
answering the call when they're driving
someplace they'll go straight to the
location but are they required to go to
the station to get the station gear or
that's not a uniform that's not uniform
so so some volunteer firefighters carry
their Gear with them in their vehicle
and respond directly to the scene some
report to the fire
station to acquire gear and get on
apparatus that that is there is no
uniformity in the state with that it
varies from town to town I will tell you
that um one of the things
that I was always cognizant of as a
volunteer firefighter is polyester so
polyester is bad news in this business
bad bad news so because when it melts to
your flesh they have to cut it off of
you and that because of that I kept um a
couple of things in the trunk of my car
in the event I'm not a big fan of Po
polyester despite what I'm wearing right
now but um but that's something that you
know that we have have put into people's
minds keep in mind that when things are
on fire the fire doesn't care if you get
a paycheck or not so you know
we the so we look at this from a from a
career versus a volunteer
standpoint there that line is not as
important as some make it out to be as
far as you know personal protective
equipment and and the requirements of
the profession for for the life of gear
and
whatnot followup thank you so from the
protection of the firefighter be it paid
or
Volunteer Fire Fighter the gear should
be a protective gear the PPE that they
are expected to wear in terms of
fighting the fire that should be a
uniform protective gear correct so the
requirements in the conditions to which
gear is is manufacturers is governed by
the National Fire Protection Association
which is headquartered in quinsey Mass
they have been
the the regulating body of that for 135
years now so uh there is there is no
differentiation in their Universe
between whether you get a paycheck to
fight fire or not that that's irrel you
don't Globe manufacturing which is one
of the largest producers of gear in the
United States is in Pittsfield New
Hampshire when you place an order with
globe they don't ask you if are you
getting a volunteer set or a career set
you you're getting gear so I I don't
let's let's not get overly hung up on on
the distinction of of that because there
the the distinction really only applies
in the case of whether or not you're
wearing a a duty uniform during the day
or
not representive G thank you madam chair
and thank you for hearing my comment
it's really a comment not a question but
uh you really helped please no comments
in the guys of a question just a
question I just want to say that uh to
all right I'll ask you this to me it
seems that we're talking about the exact
same thing we went through for children
with fire retardant chemicals on their
pajamas that was outlawed years ago
would you agree it's sort of the same
not at all okay well thank you not at
all because because an infant is not
losing 2 and a half gallons of of water
out of their body sitting in a crib I
hope unless they're next to the furnace
um you know and that that's the real big
thing here is of course the biological
effect of sweating and absorbing and
what heat does to certain types of
materials that that's the situation here
um
it's not I wouldn't I wouldn't tie those
two
together thank you for um for clarifying
it's even worse point my point was we
protected babies years ago we owe our
you thank you madam chair okay any other
questions thank you representative
Pearson for volunteering that
information is there anyone else who
wish to testify on House Bill
1435 I don't see
anybody so I will close the public
hearing and open the hearing on House
Bill
1079 and I believe representative appr
will introduce it for us 107 1079 excuse
mistake 1079 is first 1070 is at
that I I was
confused thank you representative PR and
he's bringing us an
joy representative Pro I see you're
replacing a oneline insert with a
five-page
Amendment
exponentially my name is uh
representative Mark PR representing
Hillsboro 15 good morning Madam chair
and the rest of the committee what
started out
as a
quick changing or adding a
definition
um let me give you a little history on
critical incident stress management we
I've been doing it for pretty close to
40 years um and for the longest time I
was the only team in New Hampshire but
now we're up to around seven some are
police some are
combination um I'm uh my team the grite
state critical incident stress
management team uh provide services to
please Fire
EMS um pretty much any emergency
responder and we are now reaching out to
include Hospital emergency room staff
right because we pick up a bunch of crap
on the on the street and we walk into
the emergency room and drump that crap
on their stretcher so uh they run into
the same chaos the same uh stress
responses that we do uh and for the
longest time they had nobody to get this
service
from so once I put in this bill I heard
from
uh the police department uh Southern New
Hampshire police team but they're also
doing police fire and EMS now that they
thought while we're opening this
up to and what this really is doing for
us is giving us the same protection
that mental health uh providers have
with their clients right it's
confidential um canip Peno all those
things so to do that we have to have
them listed in
here so we've opened up the the
definition we're going to use the um
homeland security definition of First
Responders and we're also going to add
that hospital emergency room staff which
is
on I believe it's I on the second page
page to protect the confidentiality when
we're working with the hospital
staff we also added
retirees into the
mix because they are an important
part uh one for being able to deliver
the service but also receiving that
service right
um we look at retirees that when they
retire they walk away from the support
system that they had right when they
working they can talk to their fellow
fire police or whoever about what's
going on with them right because we
share the same
experiences but when we walk away from
our job we walk away from that support
system and we find that our suicide rate
in
retirees is rapidly climbing because
they're not getting these Services they
don't feel they have access to them and
we want to make sure they know that
they're covered and we are working very
hard to reach out to them as we
speak to prevent that right not only are
our retirees suicide rates climbing
but all the First
Responders are and I like I don't like
to say it but my statement is that we're
kind of in a race with the
military to see who can be on the top of
that pile that nobody wants to be
on so we need to make sure that we can
provide these
services and that the people who are
providing the services feel confident
that what they say will be protected
otherwise they won't come they will not
come right especially the police right
because some of the things that they
deal with are
are pretty significant right not that
anybody else is less but they get more
scrutiny from their supervisors well
what did you say in there right and and
and has happened in the past that
supervisors had sat them down and said
we want to know what you said in there
or what was said in there and and I know
of one police officer that went to jail
and contempt the court because he would
not tell them what was said before we
protection so I don't want to see that
happening because we missed somebody in
the definitions here so that's why
there's a lot more um added and you'll
notice that a lot of it is just
repeating the new definition in certain
spots and again like you said we added
the hospital one that's a completely new
one that we we really wanted to make
sure we're making sure that the 911
operators are included because they
weren't they are not technically
dispatchers we had dispatchers they are
tele communicators right they answer the
phones but they listen to some horrible
things on the phone right and and the
imagination is a terrible terrible thing
and and I can tell you from experience
so
I ask that um we get this moved through
to make sure our Our First Responders
are taken care of and I have some other
people that will also testify but with
that I'll close my testimony and take
them thank you are there any questions
represent Bara I have a question to the
chair is there someone from New
Hampshire um Hospital Association that
will be speaking I believe they are
behind me and that's where this
definition came from okay we had if
there is anyone here who plans to
testify please turn in a pink card so we
know M sorry I forgot to drop it on my
way by yes but if there's someone from
the hospital Association or whatever I
don't have any other cards on this bill
so please turn them in now I guess it's
just me then so that definition came
from the hospital Association we had
another one previously uh and we had a
meeting with them and they uh didn't
really like it and gave us the better
definition that's why it that's what's
in here
now thank you okay any other questions
for representative Schmidt thank you
madam chair so that it's just
a so th this is not a new bill right no
this is it says it's an amendment so you
already brought us the original 1079
y so it's already in statute it's been
in statute for a long time so we are
just doing some housekeeping on that
making sure that all the people like
retirees got covered the
telecommunicators got covered and the
only thing we're really adding is the
hospital emergency room staff or
emergency department staff I I I get
that but the thing is that this is not
in the usual form it's the unusual form
of a of the of an amendment yeah the
earlier oh great so that was never mind
so that was my original Amendment just
to add the hospital staff and then they
I heard from other people who said hey
while we have this going in maybe we
should add these things that we've been
thinking about adding for a while but
didn't really want to open it up
others represent bti thank you madam
chair um thank you representative for
taking my question how does this differ
from Employee Assistance or employee
mental Wellness uh so approach this
differs as we are
peer driven right
so as far as I'm concerned the person in
in in the employees assistance program
has no idea what my job is
none right so when I tell them
my what's going on with me they're going
to go
what we have mental health people on our
teams we make them ride in police cars
fire trucks ambulances and hang out with
us right
so we don't just go to any mental health
provider because frankly unless they've
been trained and know who we are we
scare the crap out of them quote unquote
that I've been told from mental health
professionals you know I've heard
stories where someone would be in the
middle of their story telling them what
what was going on the mental health
person would cry and walk out of the
room so that's why this is different
that's why this works for us is is that
we're relating to people who know have
walked a mile in my
shoes so they know what's what I'm
talking about and and can help me get
through it because they've probably been
through it
already thank
you I noticed that you have a much
better definition of what's confidential
than in current statute so thank you for
that that was one of our goals all right
Bren good morning Madam chair members of
the committee uh just for clarification
my name is Justin Bretton b t n I am
here and representing the Manchester
Police Department our peer support and
CISD team um as well as a coordinator
for our Southern New Hampshire critical
incident stress management
team excuse me and and the New Hampshire
Police Association I wanted to thank the
committee this morning first and
foremost for your attention to this very
important update to our existing
Privileges and protections to this
statute um just a little bit of History
this was established back in
2012 um so we have been very fortunate
to have this protection for our
employees since
2012 um this has absolutely helped us
save lives of countless First Responders
at this point I'm sorry that is my
comfort dog partner so he does therapy
work in in crisis response only so he's
going to come might come check on
everybody this morning um as I was
saying this is a very important piece of
legislation that's helped us save
countless lives at this point of New
Hampshire's First Responders and we're
extremely lucky to have this Statute in
place um some of the edits that Mr PR
was discussing are like he said and I'll
use his term a lot of it is housekeeping
um some of the the terminology
that you're seeing us look to correct
with this edit um is to reflect some of
the work that we've been doing on the
pts committee um and defining things and
making sure that our New Hampshire First
Responders are protected and taken care
of after they respond to critical
incidents um so that's why you see some
of the terminology changes that you do
um as we talked about and I'd like to
address the representative's question in
regards to the difference of peer
support and EAP I think that that's a
very good question um because there are
many departments across the state in all
of the first responder community that do
have EAP programs stood up in place for
their employees what this members some
of members of this committee have heard
us testify to in the past is that there
are still some unfortunate barriers for
first responder Personnel to access EAP
programs I'm not sure if anybody in here
has ever picked up the phone and had to
make that call to an EAP um but I can
assure you that it's a less than
personable experience um most of the
time the the voice on the other end of
the line isn't even from this part of
the country um they don't know the
department that you're calling from um
and they have very limited ability to
connect with the First Responders that
are reaching out to access and and ask
for help um oftentimes you're left
waiting on the on the line for minutes
at a time hoping that the right person
answers the phone to get you connected
to the services that you need um and
quite frankly if you're in a crisis
situation and you're reaching out and
have to sit on hold listening to music
and or a narrated prompt most First
Responders are going to hang up the
phone um and so what the peer support
teams are doing across the state is we
are genuinely the bridge that Bridges
the gap between culturally competent
Community licensed Community Mental
Health Providers and our peers and I
think it's essential that we continue to
have the ability to do this or we will
continue to lose First Responders to
suicide in the State uh I think I I
appreciate representative Maguire
bringing up the fact that a big portion
of our modifications to this statute are
really trying to clarify for everybody
the limitations to this to this level of
confidentiality because it is important
for that to be laid out very clearly for
everybody um that starts on line 22 on
the second page and I think that you
know we were these teams were with the
exception of Mr PR and I say this with
all due due respect in 2012 when we
wrote this we were all pretty young and
we were new at this game representative
PR had a lot of experience at that time
and he's taken a lot of leadership along
the way and and mentored many of us as
we've worked through and had a better
understanding of how to do this work
well um and so what we've heard from
very many agencies across the state is
we they would like us to clarify for
everybody the limitations of that
confidentiality I think that I hope that
when you read those edits you'll see
that we are this is truly a support
service that's meant to protect not only
our officers but the community
um you know we this was initially um
something that was very important to
have in there so that way everybody
believed in the system and how it worked
um and knew that when the when the need
arose we were going to act and continue
to get people help prevent crimes and
make sure that people were connected to
the appropriate services so we greatly
appreciate your time and the ability to
clarify a couple of those points for the
committee this morning thank you are
there any questions repres man
py thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question so since 2012 this
was established you said the peer
support um is there any data or
statistics to show the decline in
suicide or adverse effect for First
Responders I wish there was a a very
good data set I think what we have to
acknowledge not only as uh a profession
um but also as a committee is that these
these losses are unfortunately very
underreported not only in New Hampshire
but also across the state um we're
actually doing some work on our pts
committee um Senator Burell just
presented that to hopefully reinstate us
for for another session um and our hopes
for this this legislative session is to
really focus on that we've been having
some very productive conversations on
how we are going to collect that data so
we can have a true understanding of the
scope of the problem here in New
Hampshire and also be able to come
forward and show that we are having a
positive impact with these types of
Employee Services programs um but
unfortunately there isn't a mechanism in
place to at accurately collect that data
at this time okay um I can say that
there is a nonprofit that's recognized
nationally that does collect this data
um and the and the numbers are they are
all relied on self-reporting um the
numbers for last year were 118 law
enforcement suicides across the country
and at at least 2 five in the fire
department Community um also impacted by
this and and reflected in the statute
are Corrections Personnel um Emergency
Services dispatchers um and they are
also impacted by the cultural barriers
to accessing culturally competent
Community Mental Health okay thank you
representative Brown uh thank you madam
chair thanks for taking my question yes
sir thank you could you just more slowly
tell me who you represent and what is
the pts committee I missed all that yes
sir uh I'm sorry uh as I said my name is
Justin brenon I am an officer at the
Manchester Police Department uh and I
also am here in representing New
Hampshire Police Association NH HPA um I
am the team coordinator for not only our
in-house peer support team in Manchester
um but I also I'm the coordinator for
the Southern New Hampshire critical
you thank you very much I don't see any
other questions questions is there
anybody else who wishes to testify on
House Bill
you good morning Madame chair for the
record Ben Bradley I'm the vice
president of state government relations
for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association I do not have prepared
testimony for you this morning however I
would like to express our support for
the amendment from representative PR I'm
okay
Manti thank you madam
chair what is your total number of
emergency room
employees does that include the
Physicians as well as everybody else in
the department I do not have that
information
prepared for you this morning I do not
know follow up follow up is that
available
readily um I don't believe we have any
standing reports from our members that
would indicate the total number of
Emergency Department
Personnel uh across the
fluctuating other questions all right
thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else who
wishes to
testify and I think since we have this
amendment we should send this to
subcommittee also because since we have
one
also marks excuse me
Matt's
yep okay in that case I'll close the
public hearing on House Bill 1079 we
p.m.
room
back I'm trying to open the hearing on
House Bill 1070 and I don't see any
sponsors
representative you are a co-sponsor
representative leus would you please
bill well you give you a chance chance
to chat since you won't be able to ask
them all right little lot of breath ran
over here but um for the record I'm
representative Tony
luus uh District Hillsboro 38 uh towns
of Hudson and Lichfield
and
uh this
is related to
uh dealing with the state of emergency I
mean there were I know there were
various concerns um raised about the
recent
um state of emergency and different
views on it but um the idea here is to
make sure that uh to make it
clear that no branch of the uh
government should be involved in
suspending civil liberties or of either
the us or the New Hampshire
Constitution now you'd think that would
be obvious but there were some things
that went on that uh you know could
certainly been viewed that
way uh the ones that I remember in
particular were related
to limiting what could be done in uh
places of worship churches synagogues
that sort of thing putting restrictions
on them that was quite a bit more
significant even that on uh a lot of
commercial
establishments big box stores grocery
stores and things like that so you
there's some evidence that there was a
an actual problem and this is uh in
response to
that I'm not the prime sponsor on this
but I certainly uh support
it that's all I have thank you are there
questions from the committee
represent
gr I guess I want some clarification
because in the bill it says no state
employee department or agency but you
mentioned churches and grocery stores so
I'm where's the am I misunderstanding
what you said can you speak closer to
the microphone oh sure
sorry uh it's a little hard to tell how
loud or not I am from here um the issue
was enforcement that was taken against
the churches and all of that by the
state government in particular requiring
them to close or putting
limitations on what they could do around
um having people attend during the uh Co
state of emergency that's the
relationship
connection other questions represent
Andy thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
um Co Public Health was one emergency
that you mentioned are the other example
of emergency situation would it include
floods and um natural disaster situation
where the state put an
emergency well um yeah the typical
emergencies are due to natural disasters
floods ice storms and that sort of
thing I mean I could imagine come up
with scenarios where um it could be an
issue there but I have I don't
recall um any situation where there's
been a state of emergency that's the
kind of normal weather related one where
this has been raised at an issue so and
I don't want to get into doing some
far-fetched hypothetical but in the
normal course of dealing with those
emergencies I don't know of any uh
problem like that that's come up it's
it's more the you know some wider larger
thing that's
um um you know a different sort of an
emergency and you know I hope we never
have another emergency other than the
normal dealing with natural disasters um
but given the experience we'd like to
make sure that that's not something
future okay represent black I have a
question RSA 445 Roman 3A says that not
withstanding the above civil liberty
shall on no account be suspended nor
shall the United States Constitution or
the New Hampshire Constitution be
suspended so why are you saying this is
to tell the tell every organization to
follow the law um I don't have that RSA
in front of me and I didn't draft this
bill um you know I can take a look at it
and and provide an answer to that but um
you know if if if
the if the language is in the statute
now except enumerating the parts of the
executive branch then then that might be
the
case ah thank you that's a point
representative
chair so uh thank you representative
leus for bringing this bill um and tell
me given the fact that the the suggested
addition
uh to um the U statute um was not yet in
effect uh can you give us some examples
of um
occurrences that would have in your view
uh violated this provision had it been
in effect um well first of all as as was
asked by uh the
chair um you know this may already be
something which Al although in other
words is already um illegal um if that's
the case then in my view um that part of
the statute was
violated uh during the co co emergency
may you know there may be a number of
things but in particular as uh religious
uh institutions were dealt with as
religious institutions were dealt with
because they were required to close or
had much more serious limits on them
than other organizations like grocery
stores or you know big box stores or any
of that which um so there was they were
singled out
arguably um or at least there wasn't the
uh they weren't seen as important and so
there weren't concessions or or
accommodations made that were made for
things like grocery stores and other
types of things and that's the concern
and so if this were in place there at
that time then yes what was done would
have violated this now as the chair
asked it might be that it's already
illegal in which case St statute was
violated by
that statute that was I apologize if my
question was repetitive but given the
fact that you were speaking so much
softly I apologize in a large room yeah
I wasn't quite sure I was picking up
your meaning and I don't ever want that
I understand one of the problems here
sitting here is it's hard to tell how
quiet or loud I'm coming through the mic
I'll wave at you in the next
time okay thank you any other questions
seeing none all right thank you thank
you for your testimony is there anyone
EXA
okay thank you we'll uh not EXA this in
1:45 yes
sir hear your voice to
also
mhone given the distance you are from
the
good good afternoon welcome back to Edna
I'm opening the hearing on House Bill
1267 and I call the prime sponsor
representative
elure thank you madam chair members of
the
committee I have uh just provided a
handout which is executive order
23-3 signed by the governor on April
10th of last year I would ask that you
note that the language of my bill is
submitted was taken verbatim from this
executive order with only minor
made the term
ESG is an industry standard term and as
industry I would note that the executive
order as signed last year only prohibits
investing in ESG funds if ESG is the
sole reason for that investment now the
reality is that no funds are invested
solely based on ESG technically I don't
believe that would even be an investment
it it would be something else um and
somehow if somebody managed to do so it
it would be virtually impossible to
prove that as such the executive order
is written and currently existing in uh
in rules is entirely unenforceable
and makes no meaningful progress against
fighting the ESG
cartel now why do I call it the ESG
cartel ESG exists as a public private
partnership that utilizes carrot stick
methods such as those employed by the
Human Rights Campaign where they are
tasked with scoring organizations based
on political and social activist
criteria
these scores are then
weaponized by a combination of public
and private sector actors to limit
access to capital for those who do not
score high enough and to reward those
who do by directing mostly other
people's retirement funds to these
organizations this process in
theory could be said to make ESG
profitable but the reality is that it is
a monopolistic cartel manipulating the
free market and the only profits that
come are the ones that come through the
weaponization of this carrot stick
model
also in this manner you will see why I
did not choose to Simply word my bill to
prohibit anything any kind of investing
except that of those solely directed
toward maximizing gains
because of this cartel mechanism that is
in place a fund manager could credibly
make the argument that by cooperating
with the cartel activity they are
seeking to maximize gains because they
stick in this manner the ESG cartel
represents the financial engine of the
cultural
revolution the New Hampshire
Constitution under the SE
on inculcating values outlines strictly
that we as a body shall take all
necessary measures to disrupt and Crush
anti-competitive monopolistic and cartel
marketplace this prohibition on ESG
investing is easily distinguished from
non-g
investing simply put those Investments
seeking to maximize gains without regard
to the cartel activity and doing so in
keeping with governmental regulatory
Frameworks do not represent ESG
investing only those Investments wherein
gains are knowingly
forone toward activism or wherein the
only argument for maximizing gains is
dependent on an expectation of the
continuation of cartel activity to
realize those
gains that is ESG
investing so why criminal penalty to
this when you seek to utilize These
funds for which there is an expectation
on the part of the investor that their
gains will be
maximized to cooperate with the cartel
and to prioritize social and political
activism you
necessarily are purposely foregoing some
unknowable amount of gains to accomplish
this
purpose this is tantamount Broad
and the funds we are discussing today
represent such a substantial chunk of
money that that degree of theft or fraud
would easily clear the necessary amounts
to be a felony
offense this is not their money to wield
as a weapon against their
opposition this money belongs to the
people who are expecting a
retirement and this is a common sense
measure to protect that retirement I'd
be happy to take questions thank
you us thank you um so this question is
is related to um why you believe this is
necessary I mean in statute today the
retirement system can only do
Investments you know related to their
fidu responsibility in other words you
know the best long-term the best in
return over whatever the appropriate
time scale is consistent with acceptable
risk and um I don't remember what it did
in the Senate we had a bill to require
the treasure to do the same thing for
other funds so given that and given that
um you know what you said about they're
going to forego gains to accomplish some
social activity it would seem that
um you know that right now there is a
Prohibition unless against investing
these things unless
somehow um you know it's it's reasonable
to believe and experience shows ongoing
that it is in fact um the best
investment and and and I asked that
question even though I basically agree
with your general view about ESG but the
question is you know do we need to put
something specifically about that in
statute thank you for the question I
would offer uh two Avenues of response
first um as I said uh fund managers
could reasonably under ESG guidelines
make a credible argument that they are
seeking to maximize profit because
they're looking to benefit from the
monopolistic cartel activity that is
occurring and they're expecting that to
continue into the future um which could
produce a source of Revenue uh that
could be
profitable the second reason I would
offer is because the executive branch
believed that this was important enough
to do something about the unfortunate
fact is their order is unenforcable but
that's what I'm seeking to
fix okay thank
you need to follow up um I mean you only
follow-up would be that I mean did you
know realize that the at least for the
retirement system they're supposed to
they're required to actually do their
own analysis and not just accept you
know whatever is put out there by a fund
manager and so they're going to have
their own fiduciary responsibility look
into this and see if they believe that's
actually true um so again it's it just
goes into asking whether this is really
necessary yes I I would offer when I
when I said fund manager I should have
been more expansive to say that any
person managing such funds could
credibly make this argument that because
of the expectation of ongoing cartel
activity they could actually produce
profit through this methodology even
though it's clearly against the New
Hampshire uh provision in our
constitution against cartel and and anti
uh anti-free Market behavior all right
thank
you any other questions thank you
representative thank you very much
representative
parkeran
could I just ask representative beler
since you were making prep giving us
prepared remarks would you be uh willing
to share your your your remarks with the
committee I would be happy to copy past
them an email if that's sufficient
you
representative corkran co-sponsor of the
Bill thank you for your
time um first of all I'd like to uh just
go on record is agreeing with everything
that representative Belcher said there
are two main arguments that I have
against ESG one of them moral one of
them
utilitarian the moral one is obvious
that if you are allowing a state
employee to invest on something other
than compounding retirees funds as
quickly as possible you are
deprioritizing what all of the employees
or excuse me the retirees and current
employees are looking forward to and you
are prioritizing a uh unelected you know
office worker to inject their own morals
now maybe those morals align with yours
maybe the office worker is a member of
the Knights of Columbus and they're
going down some sort of Knights of
Columbus um approved uh groups that
invest in you know a certain Catholic uh
Le organization in Germany and this
other you know mining concern in
Argentina and so forth and so on in
which case you're like okay uh this
doesn't you know horrify me probably
some good is being done or perhaps the
um morals and ideology of the office
worker are contrary to your
own um you know a pro-life person might
be very upset that their money is being
invested in firms that take active steps
uh in the other
direction I think that the culture war
in the US is already all consuming
enough uh that we do not need to have uh
Advocates showing up at these meetings
saying you know the governor has to fire
so and so and put in someone else so
that you know my preferred investment
strategy is used when we are sort of
squandering some of our potential
returns for
retirees um if we default to just
pragmatic mathematical hey let's you
know go into an index fund um you know
hedge appropriately Etc uh then this is
an entire um front in the culture war
that we don't expand to and we can just
prioritize you know I I think we're all
happy to live in a world where we can be
confident that the roads outside are
paved by The Firm that put in the best
quote not the best quote from a firm
that had politics similar to the uh you
know DPW
commissioner the second argument I have
is utilitarian and uh it just goes over
some of the same space uh that
represented belra touched on which is
anytime you put in a second priority you
are deprioritizing the first issue if we
were running a um uh a Symphony and we
are looking for the best violinist in
the world that person is out there um
and we can rank order you know there's
the top 10 or 15 but if we say hey let's
get the best Albanian violinist I'm sure
Albania has some good violinists it's
even possible that the world's best
violinist is Albanian but probably if we
limit ourselves the top violinist we're
going to get is the 31st best violinist
and the next one is going to be the 73rd
that's just a simple matter of when
you're looking in any data set and
trying to you know limit or filter by a
certain thing it is very unlikely that
you're going to get as good results um
and uh that is you know representative
Belcher did a great job uh and so he
stole about 80% of my lines I'm happy to
answer questions thank you are there
questions representative laus thank you
this kind of uh relates to the earlier
questions you said that if you have uh
more than one criteria you're going to
water down what the main goal is well
right now the the one and only criteria
they're permitted is you know the best
return over the appropriate time period
with a uh you know uh reasonable risk
now personally I think the chance of an
ESG fund having the best return
especially over the longer term is
extremely low but still if you're going
to prohibit it then you're um aren't you
U removing that as an option for good
return by the way it's it's not the
retirees that are going to be hurt it's
the taxpayers who are going to cover the
gap
that's a great question and uh you know
I don't think it deals a a good blow to
the argument but certainly it had some
hoisted on petard uh or if I said you
know hey if you filter away 99% of the
funds the remaining 1% and you're saying
you know but if you filter away 1% of
the funds might that not have included
the best funds and uh that is true um
however given that ESG are relatively
small uh percentage of funds and given
that there have been studies showing
that ESG funds consistently underperform
um the CR IA behind ESG funds are
usually fairly restrictive so they
immediately knock out you know sort of
every defense contractor every you know
small arms manufacturer anyone who emits
carbon um so you end up first of all as
a percentage of all of the funds in the
market uh really radically constricting
it and then second of the things that
those funds invest in so sort of a
second order thing are also hugely
restricted so while it is possible uh
that just out of dumb luck a particular
ESG fund might be the best in the market
I think in the real World you'd probably
have to get you know 2,000 years of
returns before You' find one year where
it would have worked the other way right
I don't disagree thank you don't argue
with them representative
leus are there any other
questions thank you very much thank you
for your time Mr
[Music]
Carlin thank you Madam chair uh Marty
Carlin representing the New Hampshire
retirement system I do have some uh
statement um on House Bill 1267 I'm not
going to read it entirely into the
record but I would like to refer to
pieces of it and initial comment about
uh this bill um as many committee folks
who've been on this committee for a
while um know NH HRS generally does not
take a position on
legislation uh regarding benefits
changes things like that or
administration of the system um however
when there are fiduciary or plan
qualification issues uh the board may u
opt to U oppose a bill uh our board
hasn't had a chance to vote on uh this
and another bill proposed in the Senate
yet they're meeting in um in a couple of
weeks but the uh legislative Committee
of the board which was five of the 13
members is going to be unanimously
recommend to the board uh that they
oppose this legislation on both
fiduciary and plan qualification grounds
um generally speaking um we're not cons
it's the opposition isn't about ESG and
in in uh in a vacuum it's it's um
generally any changes uh legislative
changes mandates to um the investment
program could potentially limit limit or
in some cases run counter or two our
fiduciary duty to act solely in the best
interest of the membership at all times
um couple of statutory and
constitutional citations I just want to
put into the record is uh RSA 100 A51 a
A1 uh which as a a151 is a definition of
fiduciary duties that's modeled on the
Internal Revenue code um and it includes
that TR the board and independent
investment committee must make all
decisions quot solely in the interest of
participants and
beneficiaries um besides the statutory
section the article 36a of the New
Hampshire Constitution reads in part uh
all the assets proceeds and income there
from from the New Hampshire retirement
system dot dot dot shall be held
invested or or dispersed in trust for
the exclusive purpose of providing such
benefits and shall not be encumbered for
or diverted to any other purposes so
in in English we the goal has always
been to make prudent long-term investing
Investments to maximize a value for our
participants and for taxpayers in New
Hampshire uh and choose Investments that
give us the best chance of meeting or
exceeding our assume rate of return uh
over the long-term while balancing risk
and and liquidity uh concerns uh ESG
which is has multiple definitions I
don't think there's agreed upon full
definition for it but regardless of
whether you would say that agree with
that or not neither ESG or any
non-pecuniary factor is considered as an
end unto itself um in investment
decisions it's one of many factors
viewed in regard to the potential impact
on our ability to obtain the highest
return so um it's not disqualifying and
it it's not qualifying it's it's it's
one of many factors if you were going to
take a trip across cross country you
wouldn't just look at the weather report
you'd look at the condition of your
tires and what you know the you know
there's a lot of things that go into
making an investment decision as a
fiduciary and this doesn't control
anything so any any attempt to sort of
limit the the scope of finding the best
financial opportunities to invest in for
our members whether it's investment
divestment what have you you know could
could constrain their fiduciary duty to
act in the bank best interests at all
times now since there was a similar Bill
proposed last year in the house house
bill
339 uh that was amended uh to a
quarterly reporting requirement and
since that took effect uh for both
Treasury and and for nhrs uh we've been
submitting quarterly statements to the
uh legislative budget Assistance Office
uh they were in compliance with our duty
to make all investment decisions solely
in the interest of the participants and
do not have any Investments and any fund
that have mixed rather than sole
investment in motivation so not only are
we doing it we're certifying to it on a
quarterly basis um this opposition in
general again not to the specific Bill
about the specific topic uh but
opposition to
legislative
um mandates involving Investments is not
new back in the 80s um there was a
movement uh on called the McBride
principles where um to divest from
companies that weren't doing enough uh
for underrepresented minorities in
Northern Ireland I.E Catholics and at
the time um and HRS uh opposed that and
its external Council made the point
which which we continue to agree with
that
um using any other Factor would um mean
we were no longer using the exclusive
purpose of providing benefits is our
sole
investment uh motivation it would also
be it would also be a Divergent
collateral purpose of affecting social
or political change so uh in summary we
believe that this legislation could only
limit our ability as fiduciaries to act
solely in the best interest of our
membership and maintain our status as a
qualified pension trust We Believe
existing law already uh serves that
purpose and this is
unnecessary thank you are there any
questions I'd like to say that I did
receive the quarterly report from both
the retirement system and the state
treasurer that they are investing as
appropriately as
necessary I'm on the list of
designated
recipients all right thank you Mr Carlin
hamberton
are you all
ready good afternoon my name is Hunter
hamberlin I'm the state policy manager
for the taxpayers protection Alliance
TPA is a nonpartisan nonprofit consumer
and taxpayer Watchdog
organization I would like to first start
off by thanking chair will McGuire and
the rest of the committee members for
allowing me to testify today
respectfully TPA opposes hb1 1267 an act
relating to prohibiting ESG standards
and government Investments I've already
submitted written testimony and a
coalition letter uh in regards to this
bill and for the purposes of everybody's
time I'm just going to give the
highlights so first off we believe this
legislation to be arbitrary as some of
the other testifiers have said uh
there's already legislation on the books
that kind of deals with this stuff uh
specifically the legislature passed HB
457 last year and the governor passed an
executive order to minimize risk and
maximize Returns on State Investments
hp1 1267 does not build on either of
these policies and it would do more harm
than
good second there is no crime in
investing in ESG yet this bill would
make it a felony to consider ESG
criteria in certain State funds Banning
investment and ESG funds limits options
for investors as does mandating
investment and ESG funds investment fund
managers like other testifiers have said
they have a legal and fiduciary
responsibility to their clients already
government involvement like this bill is
unnecessary and
counterproductive lastly ideologically
driven
bans uh or mandates for funds to
consider ESG standards only harm
citizens retirement accounts and waste
taxpayer dollars pensions and investment
should be protected from
politization and we should not have bans
or mandates on investment decisions that
don't deal with maximizing the return
any approach to ESG that is not
neutral uh has the ability to harm
taxpayers and cons consumers TPA
respectfully opposes this bill and
respectfully um requests that y'all
reconsider this legislation I thank you
for your time and I'm happy to answer
any questions that I can thank you are
questions represent yes
sir here you seem to be presenting us
with a prepared set of remarks have
youed yes sir so I submitted written
testimony um which is a little bit more
specific but this oral testimony just it
goes right from the written testimony
great thank you yes sir and then I also
submitted this uh Coalition which kind
of gives the principles of being
neutral thank you other
questions all right thank you very much
for your testimony thank you all
Michelle
vzy
good afternoon I'm Michelle theey I am
with New Hampshire businesses for social
responsibility which is an organization
of over 240 businesses in the state and
and as well as stakeholders um who are
interested in exactly the things that
are compose ESG the environmental social
and governance factors
um my testimony which you have in
writing shares that ESG factors work to
strengthen financial performance if if
hb1 1267 actually seeks to maximize
return for State investment ESG
evaluation is designed to support that
very goal too often the acronyms become
partis become targets for partisan
politics and the true value of or
meaning of of their use gets lost ESG
ratings are used to understand how a
company is doing relative to others on
important issues like protecting
consumer data and privacy worker
training chemical safety executive
compet compensation and more would you
want to know whether a company you're
investing in has major Financial Risk
because they're not properly managing
contaminated
Wastewater these are the basic me
measures that help Professionals in
financial management Fields understand
all of the risks and opportunities that
might be material to long-term financial
success this kind of analysis is similar
to the steps that a bank requires when
any of us are trying to secure a
mortgage on our homes and we personally
require in order to make sure that we're
protecting our investment most of us
would not consider signing on the da
line before having a home inspector
verify issues like lead leaks or mold
and certainly not without a clear title
search it's important to know that your
investment starts off strong or that you
at least know where what you're up
against taking away tools that a
financial professional deems important
limits their ability to make the
strongest possible decisions imagine
that instead of buying a home you're
responsible for investing Millions even
billions of dollars on behalf of other
people and not just the dollars for any
people the retirement Savings of
hardworking public
employees should those be limited to
just short-term
profits or should you take into
consideration the risks a company might
face in the future or other factors
known to materially impact a firm's
long-term financial performance and
ability to thrive in a rapidly changing
World ESG is used because it provides
value both to companies trying to access
assess their own progress which is why
90% of the
S&P um companies create ESG reports and
more importantly they're valuable to
investors understanding a company's in
environmental track record how it treats
its Workforce and the transparency of
its Financial controls allow for both
responsible and profitable investing for
these reasons we encourage this
committee to vote to oppose HB
1267 thank you and I'm happy to take
questions if there are any thank
you I don't see any so thank you for
Maham uh thank you madam chair members
of the committee my name is Jim Monahan
with the dwunk group I'm here today on
behalf of siries uh which is a national
nonprofit organization uh with many
members in New Hampshire focused on uh
sustainability uh in the business
Community um we are opposed to um House
Bill
1267 um and as my as is my practice
often times bills like this I start from
the back of the bill and work my way up
and the fiscal note I think is quite
telling and the representatives of
retirement fund I think did a admirable
job of uh walking the committee through
uh the uh the challenges that it would
create um which inform the fiscal note
um as I work my way back up through the
bill I also was um you know it has been
mentioned here but I think it uh it
strikes me as a relatively extreme
provision of the bill and that is
creating a felony that would imprison
somebody from for up to 20 years uh for
undertaking their uh work uh fulfilling
their fiduciary
responsibility um I had presented uh
testimony to you from series and I won't
read that to you but I will attempt to
summarize it and answer any questions
that you all may have um uh in essence
what the uh the bill is doing is asking
the state government to interfere with
the uh Financial professionals judgment
and fiduciary responsibility um as has
been stated by uh others here today the
consideration of ESG is a part of that
fiduciary responsibility um and
shouldn't be disposed of um uh with a um
uh a government
constraint um as was also mentioned this
is not a brand new issue to the
legislature in this committee uh we
dealt with it last year with House Bill
457 and I think a good compromise was
struck there where it reinforced the
obligation to um act in a fiduciary
responsible respon responsible way and
provide information to um the chairman
of the committee and others uh in a
reporting process and that seems to be
working well um finally this is not the
uh the only state where this issue has
arisen um in recent years uh in Indiana
last year for example there was a
legislative commission that looked at
the issue and determined that it created
a $6.7 billion Financial would create a
$6.7 billion dollar Financial loss uh to
the state pension plans uh and then also
uh in recent years uh fiscal notes from
Arkansas Kansas North Dakota Texas and
Wyoming have raised similar concerns
about the risk um that bills like this
would put um on Pension funds so I've
handed in the testimony um I'm happy to
answer any questions get the committee
additional information if they need it
but uh in conclusion we are opposed to
House Bill
questions seeing none thank you very
HW
good afternoon chair Maguire and uh yep
have to get closer thank you louder yes
okay good afternoon chair Maguire and
members of the House Edna committee this
is my first time testifying before this
committee so uh I am happy to be here
and thank you for hearing my testimony
I'm here on behalf of the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire uh
on behalf of our 3700 members across the
state we are teachers par Educators Town
employees University uh faculty uh we
are those public employees that are in
the retirement system and we've got
thousands of retirees in the state as
well so we do have an interest in how
the uh funds of the state retirement
system are invested we are o opposing
this bill we are opposing it because it
would place an artificial limit on um
how the retirement system balances risk
versus the healthy rate of return that
the state expects from uh the money in
the retirement system um we are
concerned that it would get in the way
of appropriately evaluating risk on
anything that has to do with environment
social or governance issues um you
really want to know when you're
investing in a company whether there's a
huge exposure to lawsuits due to their
environmental um you know polic IES or
or something they've manufactured in the
past it would be bad to invest because
they're profitable now but there's U you
know a ton of lawsuits coming down the
pipeline you want to know that ahead of
time um so we do not feel that this bill
allows for the appropriate um balancing
of interests when you are making
Investments of money that eventually you
know is coming out of our members
pockets and needs to to be paid back to
the retirees when they retire um forcing
divestment from ESG funds has not worked
in the other states that have passed
bills like this as another testifier
mentioned uh in
Arkansas there's been a loss of 30 to 40
million a year so that's less Revenue
their retirement system is taking in
than they expected before they pass a
bill like this uh our members who pay
into the New Hampshire retirement system
with every single paycheck they pay
their portion of it they expect to be
able to retire with dignity after a
lifetime of service to their communities
you know they're out there working again
as teachers as police as Town employees
and they pay in every single paycheck
they expect the money to be invested
wisely to balance that risk and the
return and and to have the bargain
upheld when they retire so for that
reason we oppose this and thank you for
listening to my testimony I will email
it I didn't have a chance to print it
thank you thank you we will look forward
to it are there any
questions okay seeing none excellent is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
thank you very much uh my name is em
friedricks and I with 350 NH we are a
climate Justice
organization um I wanted to uh start out
by reading a list of um of companies um
AT&T Bank of America Fanny May Freddy
Mack Fifth Third Bank All State American
Family Insurance red fin
realtor.com estate Le the National
Association of
Realtors the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau KPMG Brookings
Huntington Nores Bank homes.com Legal
Services Corporation and most recently
the US
Congress now I share that list because
that is a um a limited list of just some
of the uh bodies that are currently
using data from risk factor Foundation
um risk factor which is which is a
product of the First Street um
foundation and that data set is um D
data that looks at climate risk and what
may happen to properties um so thus you
see the large concentration of real
estate bank and insurance um entities on
that list of
clients now we are seeing a a huge
movement towards Industries beginning to
pay attention to what climate risk May
mean for their investment
ments um we when we were looking for
homes in New Hampshire we um used
realter.com and redin as as some of the
real estate um guiding platforms um and
we looked at their risk factor before
deciding which home to purchase so we
knew that our major investment as a
family would not be compromised um as
climate change begins to become more and
more apparent in our state with flooding
and other
issues um I bring this all up because um
climate change risk is one of the very
important aspects that is covered under
an ESG um qualifications report and um
not all anti- uh
ESG um movements or policies are
particularly focused on denying climate
change but some of them are um
and we believe that is a a huge
disadvantage to um to New Hampshire
residents and to particularly are New
Hampshire pensioners um to not be able
to take into account the realistic risks
um that come into play with climate
change and one of the important ways of
doing that is through um looking at the
the ESG
criteria um that is all that I came
prepared to to share today um I'd be
happy to take a question if there are
questions represent man py and I just
need your name yes it's m
friedrick thank
you it's
easy right I don't see any other
testimony anyone else all right then I'm
going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
1267 and we have seven
minutes okay so
we go into executive session
representative broa did you say you have
an amendment a motion oopsie I do have a
motion I move um itl on on House Bill
1267 no
second
okay represent broa do you wish to speak
to your motion yes what motivates me to
um present this motion to the committee
is that the New Hampshire retirement
system has its own investment
criteria and that should be the one that
we
support and it should not um we should
not be swayed by testimony on either
side directing our attention to one
thing or another and they the New
Hampshire retiring system um has this
covered and their investment strategies
are the ones that are geared to benefit
those who um participate in that
fund
okay representative leus I agree with
representative grota and what I'll add
is although I I tend to uh be on the
same side of this the whole ESG thing is
the sponsors um you know everybody has
their own thing that they consider
important and um but you know trying to
use the uh investment of the pension
system to promote or oppose any
particular thing in Defence
representative Grotto I will not use the
term slippery slope but I will say it's
a very bad precedent and uh and it's not
something we should be
questions okay in that case the motion
is inexpedient to legislate and the
rule representative Lakers yes
representative
Bailey
yes represent
Dolan representative Gard
clerk votes yes representative Boyd
yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative Shu
yes representative G yes representative
Smith yes representative mapy yes and
the chair yes 13 y z
nay okay the motion passes 13 to zero
does anyone object to
consent all right seeing none we will
consent and we have four minutes before
hearing
okay so
C is Glen gonna chair or you g chair
this tell me he's next up in line okay
and so um can he go into executive
session
minut
all I was the chair of a commission on
the retirement system House Bill 145 1
is a recommendation from that
commission I am not sure if I personally
support it or oppose it but I think it
is important enough that it should be
brought to the legislature and debated
so what it does is that it
declares that for pension
purposes mandatory overtime is included
in base pay the reason for that is that
right now
overtime is included in your pension
only up to a certain percentage there
are specific calculations about how to
do it but with the Recruitment and other
issues we have some employees are
working a great deal of overtime
employer uh because you can't leave your
police station unattended you can't not
have workers in the in
Corrections you can't not have people in
the state hospital that to keep an eye
on the on the uh patients there so this
says
that for pension purposes the employer
pay the employer definition is important
because that eliminates the possibility
of
someone um manipulating their overtime
to spike their pensions which is one of
the reasons why overtime is limited if
the employer says you've got to work
tonight that's not your choice you're
not doing it to to uh inflate your
pension you're doing it because
somebody's got to be there thank you
representative
schm so
um as I said
this allows
the full amount of any mandatory
overtime to be included in base pay
which will increase pensions to some
degree for those people who are forced
to work
overtime it is already paid for because
the employee and the employer both make
contributions on the payroll not on base
pay so
it's there will be a fiscal impact of
course but it's less than it might be
otherwise and I think it's a an issue of
fairness to the employees I'll try to
answer any questions so any questions
from the
committee uh represent MRA
py thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
it's very specifically says mandatory
which means the employee has no choice
at this point so from that point of
they're not doing it to beef up their
base pay for pension correct so it seems
like a logical fair thing to say they've
done their due diligence they have
served when they are asked to so they
have to be compensated for that yes they
are paid and including
overtime overtime pay is in their
contracts but
Beyond a certain level overtime is not
necessarily included in their pension
and for some people it can be
significant the uh Department of
Corrections for example is working
significant overtime it has for the last
few years that I'm sure of and probably
before
that follow up thank you similarly the
lnas and County nursing homes and where
the good shortage of uh Personnel if it
is if the employer decides it's
mandatory over time that's what would be
included right now as as I believe Mr
Carlin will explain the employer reports
base pay and then other pay which are
handled differently but this would just
incl put the uh mandatory overtime into
the base pay line representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
Maguire you cited in your testimony a
couple of examples of uh State entities
like Corrections and state hospital
where you simply have to have somebody
there all the time uh and that's going
to involve mandatory overtime have you
looked at how what the total P at the
the total
employer um panoply is uh with regard to
how many are going to be impacted by
this change I haven't examined it in
great detail but I'm pretty sure that
teachers don't get much overtime there
are a few state employees that that do
um the the snowplow drivers for example
work work
overtime uh but I am sure that there are
some
places where it is required to keep
staff on hand and I totally agree with
you I'm just and that is the places
where there will be mandatory overtime
they are largely police fire Corrections
and a small amount in places like New
Hampshire hospital um the nursing homes
may be I hadn't thought about that but
that may be another case where you have
to keep people on hand absolutely thank
you any other questions
Carlin thank you excuse me thank you Mr
chair um Marty Carlin representing the
New Hampshire retirement system and back
in the familiar position of not having
uh the retirement system not having a
position on this proposal which is a
policy decision uh as representative
Maguire uh said already um since uh the
changes made in 2011 to the pension
system members who weren't vested by Jan
uh January 1st of 2012 have had their
pay reported differently uh folks who
were vested prior to that it was
everything was base pay everything that
was listed as earnable compensation and
the statue was treated as as base pay um
for the folks who weren't vested
and as well as current and future recent
hires um the employer is reporting base
pay as one line in the monthly report
and then compensation over base um that
includes U but is not limited to
overtime any kind of annual attendance
bonuses if there was workers
compensation supplemental pay longevity
pay uh things like that so and that's
that's not broken out by type within
comp over base uh the law also Al
calculates uh pension benefits under the
average final compensation it's a
fiveyear average and it looks at the
percentage of compensation over base pay
versus base pay in the total in the
bottom line as a percentage uh in each
year since since the data has been
available so since 2012 and then there's
a formula that if the percentage of
compensation over base in the high five
years is lower than the uh higher than
the percentage in the other years it is
um the lower percentage is applied so it
it could serve to reduce there there's
some variations with uh group two and
group one in that but just for the
purposes of this discussion you know
that's how it would work so so we see
this bill uh prospectively as employers
would be uh determining um whether uh
overtime is mandatory or not and
Reporting it in the base payline to HRS
going forward uh if uh if they make that
determination uh a proposal like this is
is extremely hard if not impossible to
put a price tag on because we don't know
how many employers are going to Define
it over time how much overtime people
are actually getting in any of the four
groups now because it's not broken out
as a separate entity as well and you
know how uh future economic Trends are
going to you know affect this benefit so
it's almost like it's going to have to
play out over time actuar based on
experience I mean I think representative
Maguire is 100% correct in saying that
probably the group least affected by a
bill like this is going to be teachers
because they tend to be contract
employees uh working a a set number of
weeks there is a lot of overtime in in
my experience with Educators but um
besides uh Public Safety uh group two um
you know again Highway workers County
nurse places where they need coverage
you know they need a set amount of
people uh they are probably um employers
may be forced to mandate people work
extra shifts just because of Workforce
issues and other things so it it's sort
of hard to to pin down what what this
would cost but um glad to answer any
questions anybody has thank you I've got
a few actually U to start with one is
representative McGuire uh mentioned As I
understood it that the amount the
employers are contributing both for the
normal cost and presuming the the amount
they pay to cover the unfunded liability
is based on total payroll and so they're
already paying um based on the amount
they paying in overtime as well as
everything else is that correct that is
correct okay and then um you know uh
presumably there will be some amount
extra paid out in uh
pensions and you know am I correct that
any such cost is going to end up
increasing the unfunded liability and
therefore increasing the amount that all
the employers have to pay for that
portion of what they pay into the
pension system it it will increase the
costs I'm not sure how much of that is
unfunded versus present value of future
benefits uh you know normal cost type
things but but yes to the extent that
any individual benefits from this change
such that their lifetime benefits going
to be larger you know that that those
funds aren't accounted for so they would
be uh paid through future employer
contribution rates just kind of a follow
up on that um since they're already
paying the employers are already paying
the amount and the employees for that
matter I guess are paying the amount
based on their total payroll this won't
cause that to go up at all so whether
it's called unfunded liability or what
it's still going to come out of that
portion of what the employers are paying
is that right it'll it'll it'll start
showing up in future employer rates over
time as experience you know in your
retirement experience but there's no
immediate you know way to Value this and
you know the next rate setting valuation
but over time if if this increases if
this proposal on in the aggregate
increases benefits by you know
05% for members or 5% you know that's
that's that's that's the variable that
we sure will need to
monitor okay and then the last one is I
think almost asking you get your Ouija
board out but I guess the thing is is
there any guess at least the order
magnitude of what the total c a million
10 million 100 million any I I
understand the difficulties so so again
this is employer defined mandatory over
time so so the closest thing you know
and this isn't Apples to Apples I mean
this this is why it's not in in in the
handout but um if you recall a couple
weeks ago this committee heard House
Bill
1653 uh and that uh made overtime for
group two tier B members part of base
pay so that was was that cohort of about
the,
1650 members in group two and the fiscal
note on that um I believe had a rate
increase that would equate out to about
3.4 million a year overall um on the
group group two contributions for state
and local employees so that this isn't
Apples to Apples but that that's that's
that's a peg on the battleship board to
to give you an
idea okay thank you for that attempt um
I don't know who was first but uh I
guess I saw represent M puty first and
then
G thank you Mr chair thank you for for
taking my question um she ear this is
I'm not saying this would affect in one
way or the other but would
you consider that this would help
retention and Workforce longevity in a
place where there is it's employer
asking for a mandatory overtime so there
is the investment from the employee to
do the overtime an employer asking and
there's a reward for the employee for
giving up their time when they didn't
ask for it so that would that uh convert
into a longevity or work for retention
yeah I I I don't think nhrs is qualified
to give a definite opinion on that
unfortunately I mean I that actually
that was one of the considerations in
the retirement benefits commission um
with that this came out of um you know
that that was part of the discussion
there um I you know I don't know if
there's anybody here from the municipal
Association or the school boards or the
counties who might have more insight
closer to the to the actual employer
base than than we are representative
groa yes I just want to do you in do you
believe
that mandatory over time is defined
enough in our system so that we know how
it would be calculated which I mean is
there enough understanding of what
mandatory overtime means so that we
don't have discrepancies between
departments what I I I think the the the
goal of this is to give the employer the
control so so mandatory is in the eye of
the the employer um you know so
they're there was no standard definition
of mandatory because the employer is
going to weigh that and
decide you
know up so because I know nothing about
I mean I just want to understand
mandatory
overtime let's say that someone needs to
fill a
slot and there's two people that raise
their hand does it become ratory over
time since two people are offering to
work you see how this can get
absolutely uh representative that that's
a good example I I'm not really versed
well enough to to make that ultimately
it's going to be up to the employer I
mean I think you know you one you know
you know either through a Personnel
policy or or collectively bargain the
definition you know on an employer by
employer
basis okay uh representative G uh my
questions were exactly what
representative Grody asked and having
been in those shoes as an employer and
an employee I think it's very fuzzy I I
think it's something to be concerned
about with this I mean one one thing NH
HRS would be cons would would monitor
through you know you know random
employer Audits and things like that is
whatever the policy is that it's
consistently applied to all members and
all groups because if if it you know it
is carve outs and things that that
become could down the road become a plan
qualification thing but just you know
consistent application of a standard is
something something we would try to
require from employers so it's not
arbitrary representative C so this um is
this consistent application is that
something then how would we how would
that happen I mean how could it do you
have Ru making or authority or anything
like that to mandate
that again you know compliance with the
statute I think just in general enal
terms would um require consistency but I
I I think you know mechanically um you
know we would probably create a form
that the board could approve for an
employer
to submit you know to you know to say
we're we're reporting overtime is
mandatory or not so we'd have a record
of who's doing it and who's not if you
know Manchester does and nashille it
dozen or something like that we we would
want to know as long as all the Apple in
the Manchester bucket or in the OR
apples and all the oranges and that you
know type of thing so so I think we
would look for some declaration or
statement or attestation from an
employer as to what they're doing so
that there's no ambigu ambiguity going
forward with folks retiring from that
employer when the time comes and again
this this doesn't affect overtime paid
over the career before the effective
date of the bill we wouldn't be able to
unscramble that egg so this is only a
forward any other questions from the
committee uh represent M py thank you
madam chair sorry thank you m chair and
thank you for taking my another question
so this is only for moving forward not
the ones that are there um already in
the system right yeah we we wouldn't
have the data to be able to go backwards
and say what was mandatory you know
after I mean no employer has deter has
defined it yet as mandatory so it you
know would only be from the point when
they can start doing
that follow up so in that case defining
what mandatory it has to come from the
employee and the employer and the need
of the hour is that something that can
be uh kind of
defined I
I
might refer back to the sponsor on the
intent of the bill but you know as
defined by the employer is pretty broad
it doesn't have criteria in which to to
make that determination it's just you
know the the you know uh proper body for
that employer making that determination
based on whatever facts they want to
factor into it so so it is you know I I
don't I don't see anything in the bill
now that has a checklist or steps to
Define what's mandatory it's
you
know okay um any other questions for Mr
Carlin okay see none thank you thank you
and uh like to call uh Brin real if I've
got the name correctly oh' Brian
ah the A's and n's left the
same that's representative Brin real ah
representative doesn't say that I'm
teasing that was from earlier all right
sorry my my joke didn't land I I
apologize for not recognizing all 400 of
us uh for the record Brian real uh
president of the professional
firefighters in New Hampshire uh thank
you committee for hearing my testimony
this morning I speak um obviously in
support of this bill and i' like to
thank representative Maguire for
bringing this forward uh I really
appreciated uh the time in the
commission working alongside her on this
um the reason why the professional
firefighters think that this is is
important is um you know I've heard it a
couple times already the Recruitment and
Retention issue in our state is not
getting better um and we need to find
creative ways to move forward on this
issue uh this is not this is not a a
restoration of a benefit from the past
although um at one at one point overtime
was considered base compensation and it
was all included in your base
calculation um this is a modif
uh restoration if you will in that we're
not asking for every Stitch of overtime
to be included back into base
compensation we're trying to be
realistic with with the ask here in that
um you know a firefighter a police
officer a correctional officer um you
know if they're required to be at work
they shouldn't then be penalized on the
back end for that um and that's our
position on this and just to to give you
an
example uh a firefighter wakes up ill on
Christmas morning and can't come to work
and another firefighter then has to stay
and is unable to go home to their
families um they're required to stay and
then they're they retirement calculation
suffers because of that now I understand
that's it's a minor it's a minor
one-time situation but this happens on
nights weekends holidays this is time
away from families uh this is forced
time on the job and it's hours worked
most of all uh it is actual hours worked
on the job uh that they should be
compensated for so I would ask for the
committee's support uh at looking into
this further and I'd be happy to answer
any questions uh representative Schmidt
and then representative Mony you ready
Brian I'm ready thank you Mr chairman
so in a sense this is mandatory over
time in the examples some of the
examples you gave for sure um
is would that be something that could be
worked into this bill because if if you
got to stay on the job you got to stay
on the job because Public Safety is
involved especially in the case of
Troopers uh then they should be they
should be wouldn't be penalized for that
so is that something you would uh
entertain if uh the if it were
workable representative I'm sorry I
guess I missed the question there
talking about holidays specifically I'm
talking about anytime a trooper is is on
D on duty and cannot leave I see because
the the scene of the accident just think
in the winter time you got a hor
horrific accident those Troopers are
going to stay until the job is done sure
um yes I that's mandatory they didn't
get an option anybody here want to work
overtime you know in a factory or
something like that they got to stay so
why shouldn't that be part of the the
the out reach of this
Bill yes I would be supportive of that I
I think um you know I don't want to get
too too much into the weeds because I
think that the defining of mandatory
overtime
removes uh being in the business myself
it REM removes a lot of the ambiguity
whether that be through uh as mentioned
by Mr Carlin earlier Department policy
Department procedure U the fire chiefs
making that determination um collective
bargaining agreements uh in many cases
the the city or town identifies what
that Staffing model looks like and
requires you to maintain a minimum
Staffing um so in in different
municipalities it may vary as to what is
uh what they're defining mandatory um
but that's what we're trying to do here
is is be consistent within those
municipalities
ities representative
mrai thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um you kind of partly
answered my question in terms of
mandatory because it's the need and this
will also provide the workforce that's
needed
today if you don't have five
firefighters to serve in the community
today one of the firefighters have to do
an overtime to fill in the
fourth um position right
so H how do you define that in and you
kind of said it goes from Community to
community it gets the municipality what
they set the standard so in from that
point with the concern of not being able
to higher retain would this uh add to
the toolbox of Workforce Force retention
and providing
adequate Workforce for today's need
thank you for your question I I can't
say with any amount of certainty but I
do believe that it is a piece of the
puzzle um and it's a piece that when we
look at what we believe to be um the the
lowest hanging fruit that it makes the
most sense this is truly a fairness
issue and when we talk about the
inability to go home and and live our
regular lives because we we swore an
oath we we have an obligation to protect
our communities um and and we take that
very seriously but also we do have lives
too and we have families um and we have
other obligations that we're not able to
attend to because we're being forced to
be held and if I could give you an
example just as a way this may work
right in the community I work in we
staff at 15 firefighters per shift the
fire chief has determined that the
minimum Staffing for the fire department
is 13 firefighters so if two
firefighters take the day off no harm no
foul no one has no one's mandatory
forced into work um if a third
firefighter takes the day off the same
day then someone needs to fill that seat
they've determined that 13 firefighters
is the lowest minimum Staffing standard
um to maintain a safe work environment
for our firefighters so that's what the
fire chief has determined as being um
the the safest Staffing model it doesn't
work that way in every Community but
that's why it's so important to
allow it to be defined by the
department representative
gr hi Mr Dr I support the fairness issue
and in principle I support the bill my
my I just would like to
know is there a way of further defining
what mandatory when you speak about it
it makes sense right
somebody it doesn't come to work so the
person that's working on the night shift
or the day shift or whatever shift it
was has to cover for that other
shift
so is there a
definition of what that
is is that is you know my previous
example where somebody doesn't come to
work but there's two people that are
willing to fill that slot that's not
really mandatory cons that's not
mandatory
overtime because either one of them is
willing to do
it so can you help me understand that
better or am I just picking at something
that can't be defined further I guess
thank you representative for your
question my first my I guess my um
hypothetical question would be
would it matter um
because it doesn't matter if you have to
pay employee a or employee B to fill
that mandatory
spot it's still going to cost a certain
percentage right and it's going to
calculates a certain percentage in
someone's overtime um I guess the
simplest way of putting it would be the
example I just gave and that a um
however it's determined whether it be
through uh Collective bargaining or city
policy or the fire chief's management
rights there is a minimum Staffing
standard uh for every Department that
must be maintained and to me the
simplest way of putting it is if it
falls below that then that would be
mandatory over time followup thank you I
think i' with your help on that
and so really in this case the employer
could be a
municipality correct so they're going to
determine for themselves through their
collective bargaining agreements with
their with their um employers or EMP
employees how this is going to be
managed so thank you I think I I'm
settled sure I think I'm
okay representative um
Dolan thank you Mr chairman um would you
be willing
to the confusion about
mandatory
um over time would you be willing to
submit an amendment that that gave a
definition of mandatory overtime to be
added add it to the bill I I would be
happy to have those conversations I I
would prefer to have that conversation
with representative McGuire who who
wrote the Bill and okay thank you um but
I wouldn't be opposed to to word
smithing it if that's what we need to do
okay U representative gold thank you Mr
chair and thank thank you for um taking
my
question your previous statement
response to representative Grody was
also very helpful to me and to to me one
of the things that jumped out was the
mandatory nature is based on the need of
the opening that exists so it the
mandatory is attached to the position if
a volunteer happens to be available to
volunteer to do that they're filling a
mandatory need and if nobody
volunteers then somebody's going to
appoint a body to do it to fill a
mandatory need so I'm wondering if that
might be a consideration to put into the
rewarding somehow that the mandat and as
you pointed out you can't write a
definition that's going to fit every
single instance because you have so many
different you know whether it's a
residential program that has to be
staffed 247 a hospital a fire department
there a municipality a state run
um they all have
different probably
definitions does that make sense yes
thank you representative it makes sense
to me and and I think that um you know
you hit the nail on the head and in that
it's a mandatory need um and that that
is going to be defined differently in
every single City and town and in every
single discipline whether be fire police
the hospitals whatever um at some point
it is defined somewhere as to what a
minimum level of acceptable Staffing is
Right otherwise you could potentially
have a fire department with two people
working um when they're supposed to have
15 so um certainly we can we
can we could work on some language if
questions okay see none thank you and
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee uh thank you for this
opportunity my name is Sean Thomas I'm
with demur and pressol and we represent
the New Hampshire Police Association as
well as the New Hampshire Troopers
Association I expect and and and that's
it's at least my goal uh that this is
the shortest testimony you hear all day
but president Mike G
uh with the Police Association president
Frank Campo with the Troopers
Association both wanted to be with you
today unfortunately they couldn't make
it and ask me uh to let you know on the
record that for the reasons um you
already heard from Brian
will that this is a very very important
issue and they strongly support House
Bill 1451 and requestly respectfully
request your support thank you okay any
questions see none thank you thank you
Pearson thank you Mr chair again for the
record Representative Steve Pearson
Rockingham District 13 which is
encompasses the town of
dairy as this is something that
is uh will affect my operations As A
Firefighter in New Hampshire I'll
disclose that as a member of the uh
retirement
system so listening to the testimony and
the questions that were
as you know the language of the bill let
let me bring it as I have with other
things to to just you know where the
rubber meets the road here right so you
have a situation where in a lot of
communities you have a staffing level
and as as Mr real estated in in
Portsmith the way they do it where they
can go down
too now to to muddy the the the blanket
definition part of this a little bit
more right so the city of Manchester is
required to have
46 so you have a sometimes the threshold
there is a lot greater is you have the
ability to have at any one time 16
people off on a
shift 16 so I I've been there 21 years I
have been forced to work at 21 years on
a mandatory
shift what that so what does that mean
right that means that I didn't go
home or didn't get to come to conquer to
go to my niece's birthday
party almost missed a flight
once mandatory
overtime and as I have stated in the
testimony in the other Overtime
Bill this is doing the same work on
Tuesday that I'm doing on Wednesday in
and yet you're treating the exact same
amount of work differently except in
this case a governmental
agency is telling me I have to stay at
work or there are
penalties this is not a
simple you don't get to go home let's
look at what this really is but when
you're forcing someone to work you are
doing it against their
will and I want that I want that to sink
in here
okay there a governmental agency forcing
a person under penalty of discipline or
the loss of a job that they must
stay and I think that that changes this
game tremendously when you're talking
about
that and it's certainly why at a minimum
it should be
treated like any other shift as far as
the calculations go now this isn't free
the employee and the employer pay their
portion as they would for the shift the
day
before so this isn't coming out of
there's no magical pot of money this has
to come out of this is this is coming
right out of the checks as it was
before so I want to I want to make sure
we understand that as well this as far
as as far as that aspect
goes now as far as the the requests for
kind of an overall blanket definition of
this
I think we got to be careful here
because I as a person who believes in
local
control as I do if we start to mess with
the local control aspect of this we're
going to run into a situation where we
have a definition that does not work for
everybody where as an
example in the case of Mr Real's
Department en pouth they can go down two
people before they have to hire my
department can't go down anybody
except that we have units in the city of
Manchester that are required to be
filled and we have units in Manchester
fire that are
not required to be filled we have a
squad unit that is not required to be
staffed so we're going to have to be
careful here if we decide to do a
blanket definition Statewide and take
away local
control that we're not either forcing a
municipality into something they don't
want to
do from from the sake of of having to
retain people or we're forcing a
municipality to
not keep someone that and that's I think
the local control aspect of this is is
is a critical part here and that's just
the fire service wise I can't speak for
how Corrections in in law enforcement
operate but you know we have communities
have different needs they have different
Staffing levels they have different
philosophies they have different
tolerances some I can tell you a
volunteer department that I worked
perdum for 20 years ago if they had if
no one showed up that day they just rent
went with nobody it would anybody which
was a little shocking to some of the
residents there but that was reality so
where does that fall into play now are
you forcing this town to create a a
mandatory minimum that they they just
currently don't have so I just urg
caution when it comes to the blanket
definition o of what this would be as
far as local control goes
the other thing I want to remind the
committee here is that overtime because
of the way our salary and benefit
structures now work overtime saves
municipalities
money because they're not paying which
is now mostly 60% of someone's
compensation packages benefits you don't
get extra Dental for showing up on on an
overtime shift
so let's not lose sight of that that
that game has changed a little bit here
and where we have municipalities right
now that are running short to save
money they are slightly exacerbating the
potential of of mandatory overtime
shifts now as far as Recruitment and
Retention goes we had a an individual
who was hired by Manchester fire who
quit after his first shift because he
was getting held mandatory and had a
newborn now I think it was probably a
little bit of a failure to explain to
that individual that the magnitude of
what a mandatory overtime shift is and
the fact that he would be subject to
that but the point is we lost an
this so where where we are so scarce and
so desperate for human resources right
now to get into a situation where you
enter into employment in New Hampshire
and emergency services and you live in
the world of potential mandatory
overtime but oh by the way we're not
going to compensate you the same way for
this forced action that we will for the
shift that you had the day
before you can see where that's going to
be a little problem atic and it costs us
an
employee the concept of it costs us an
employee so that that's where I'm going
with this and and I just I just hope
that those factors can be taken into
consideration when drafting the
parameters that you're you seem to be
asking for I have one question for
clarification then uh representative
Schmidt um so if you have a department
that's trying to save money by having
fewer employees but more
overtime um I mean is it that something
that's scheduled ahead of time and
people know they're going to have to do
it so it's not mandatory over time or is
it handled as mandatory over time that
would depend on the department I I can
there are there are cases I'm I'm not
familiar with every single Department in
the state at all not even close but I
know of cases where the the handling of
of mandatory overtime is very different
from Department to Department okay so
there's there is no blanket process or
way that that's conducted representative
schmi thank you Mr chairman uh so I I'm
as strong an advocate as you are for
local control and you mentioned this in
your testimony a couple days ago if you
recall one day you're working this
category the next day you're doing the
same job but it's different category but
the the reality is that it's kind of a
doggy dog world out there where one town
is picking off employees from anywhere
else to get them because they need them
uh and they're they're making a better
offer to that employee for whatever re
reason whether it's because it's a
shorter commute or better better pay
whatever um but to the degree that that
the mandatory overtime would be
different would work out differently in
town a than Town B Because town a is
paying more generous basis of whatever
then Town B is well that's the luck of
the draw and in terms of town a having
that situation and town B not having it
or vice versa so why is that necessarily
I I understand that there's lots of
complexities here um and it's kind of
like you know uh I don't have to give
you examples you understand uh why is it
necessarily a a a deal breaker uh to go
for mandatory overtime where it's going
to work out differently in some of the
towns and others sure in the case of of
the individual that we lost in
Manchester uh his boots landed on a
department that didn't have it right
they just didn't do it they ran they ran
down to zero MH which does not serve the
public I in my opinion does not serve
the public in any way but you know
people's life situations are very
different some people have a lot of
flexibility some do not where we have we
have a department in the state where a
mandatory overtime could be traded off
to someone that is not my department my
department does not allow that so you
know in the in the whole crusp of local
control right we don't have a standard
pay for a police officer New Hampshire
municipalities determine that pay we
don't have a standard pay for a teacher
we don't have standard pay right for for
any local entity those conditions are
set by the municipalities and they
battle it out for human resources and
Duke it out for the limited limited
folks that unfortunately we have today
so again the maintaining of local
control in this regard is is no
different that the they can set a a
situation that can attract or not
attract an employee so like I said I'm
just urging urging caution if we're
trying to have a
Statewide
definition in taking that away from
local
control any other
questions okay see none thank you Mr
chair is there anyone else here who want
1451 okay seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on that and I uh hang on are
is the chair coming back up or are you
stand out
there okay um all right so you're still
okay with the
execu what she are you saying that we
session yeah one two three four five six
without
all
right what's
up
fine all right we've had a request to go
into executive
session is there a
motion yes Madam chair I move um
1451 all right represent do you wish to
speak to your motion yes I apologize to
the committee if I took us down the um
lost path of Def finding mandatory um
overtime but I think that the testimony
that we heard after that helped me um
come to the conclusion that really the
municipalities are the employers and the
ones who are who are going to be
responsible for this and that is their
decision and therefore it should remain
there
representative gold did you we to speak
to your second uh no I I totally agree
with what representative Grody has
said representative leus thank you um I
think I'll support the OTP but yeah
there are some concerns
that while in one sense the local
employers uh are responsible the money's
coming out of the pension fund and that
is going to be paid for by all employers
um and although as was mentioned there
was a mention that the money's already
being paid because they're paying on
overtime the reality though is in a fact
that's kind of a donation to the pension
system because uh benefits aren't paid
on that you could say that's not just
and it should be fixed and I might agree
with that but it's still going to be an
additional cost that we're putting on uh
the employers so I'm not entirely happy
but um and little concerned about 28a
issues but I think I can go along with
it yes all right and anyone
else I I would agree that trying to
Define
mandatory would be an exercise in
futility because each employer would
have different ideas of what is
mandatory over time some of it is I'm
sure is decided by cor collective
bargaining but
be right and that's why this or one of
the reasons this bill explicitly says
it's the employer call on what's
mandatory because they they know the
conditions that's in and they know that
else represent leus you have a
any other comments
questions that case not per the motion
is ought to pass by representative groa
and the clerk can call the
role representative lakas yes
representative
Bailey yes representative Dolan
representative ghard yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt
yes representative Shu yes
representative G yes representative
chair yes 12 vaa z
consent all right seeing none we'll put
it on
consent and thank you all for for
participating and close the executive
subcommittees
it's actually kind of hard to hear from
here up to the other end of the room so
and it's a little
friendlier um all right we had thought
we were
going is this Lee Webster by any chance
no that's a representative never mind we
thought we were going to hear from uh
someone who was well-versed in this
subject however uh they are not
some written testimony or email
testimony uh yes I I do have
clarifications that uh the prime sponsor
um this representative lontine
sent did everyone get
that okay um I will state that um I
believe there are still quite a few
questions um revolving in around this
issue and where a lot of your testimony
previously and in in the submitted
clarification refers to Green burials I
will point out this is not technically
green burials it's not alkaline
hydrolysis green burials are in fact
permitted by Statute now so this is
technically a whole new concept that
um I I will say that for
myself um I was kind
of perplexed that the states that have
adopted this have not been able to craft
rules addressing regulating it yet and
I'd kind of like to see kind of how
those models look before we actually do
that in New Hampshire um did did you
have any other
concerns well that was part of it and I
was concerned about the cemeter operator
that felt
that
compost if they wanted to call it that
would be regulated by some federal
agency which I'm really don't want to
impose on
anybody
um
and I'm I'm concerned that some people
that are in apparently in the business
are don't don't seem to want to use the
same
terminology so it doesn't sound like
this is a a
unified um accepted process I would I
think
that
um
since green burials are already allowed
and there are green cemeteries in the
state I think there is
not not much urgency to working on
natural organic reduction which
sounds moderately unnatural to
me um so I'm I'm not not inclined to
want to to pass this bill
immediately
I will add that um I had the opportunity
to talk to the representative of the New
Hampshire Farm
Bureau uh who informed me that there are
folks in the state that do um animal
composting and that does require
permitting and sorry but we are
technically animals we're from the
Animal Kingdom so I think that
particular aspect is going to have to be
addressed uh among other things and um I
think uh what we would like to see is
for the sponsors of this bill to look at
a lot of the questions that were raised
during the hearing uh and we're talking
about probably putting this into interim
study to give you folks time to uh
investigate and answer some of those
issues and see if you can come back with
uh something that will satisfy the needs
for this
legislation um probably after the close
of session or possibly even at the end
of summer uh which is when we would be
acting on interim study bills and we can
schedule um another meeting a work
session on it if you think you have some
things that satisfy some of the issues
so that we can disc discuss it if you
care to representative
Schmidt thank you madam chairman so I I
totally agree that there are too many
unresolved issues uh I definitely don't
think the bill is ready to P to pass at
this time by the same token I think it's
it would be uh I think it would be the
wrong step to say itl because I think
there a lot of uh thought is going into
where you are already uh this place or
that place ntion Nationwide or
nationally anyway um and and uh so I
think the obvious place to go is uh to
do interim study to to work on it
because it definitely needs work but it
I I don't think it's fair would be fair
uh to the process and to the developers
and so forth of this concept to just say
you know go away and don't bother us
which is kind of what an itl does so I I
would support an interim study motion
chase I agree with um all the statements
and representative Maguire put my
thoughts into play perfectly
um I think there's way too many
questionable variables involved with
this and um I think things can be
clarified I think everyone should have
the right to um if someone wants this
type of burial for themselves but what
if they're they're not able to say they
pass away and they weren't able to to
suggest that I mean I just did way too
with worked on any for okay let's do it
would anyone else would anyone here like
to
address
yeah
um I just wanted to clarify that in
Washington state it is regulated and
it's regulated through their office of
Professional Licensing and so they
require testing of the final product for
heavy metals and um pathogens and once
they've gone through that process a 100
times then they bumped it down to 25% of
the time it has to be tested so they do
have a process in place and it is
underway there and working I think quite
smoothly um and so
you know and I I agree are you speaking
particularly about cremation now no no
natural organic reduction this is about
natural organic reduction so they
they're they have a department of
ecology I guess where we have a Dees and
their de their Department of ecology
said this is not our perview and and had
the office a professional licensure
there do it so um I do think there's a
question in play as to who wants to take
on that role in our state and making
sure that's done and we're happy to dig
into that further um I think the
question raised by life Forest I I'm not
sure what's where she's headed with that
she reached out to USDA for organic um
for the organic standards but you would
never go through that process in this
situation it's not an organic product
that anyone's trying to sell to a in
fact it's explicit in in our bill that
it is not to be used for agricultural
purposes so um I don't think that that's
an issue the your your concern about the
federal requirements but again you know
you know if we have time to work on it
now we can certainly clarify that for
you um do you
have yes and it's certainly not an
Agricultural Product um that it seemed
that um this group from light Forest
kind of went off on their own tangent
about this and no other state is the
Department of Agriculture involved in
regulating natural organic reduction it
is regulated by the same agency that
that regulates funeral homes and
inspects funeral homes and and the whole
any other uh in cremation so that they
would bring the Department of
Agriculture into this discussion was
really um no one else is doing that
um and but likewise with um you wondered
if well if you need a permit to do um
composting of animals on a farm um it it
wouldn't be the US SDA who do that but
in our bill we we clearly lay out that
if someone's going
to bring their remains of their loved
one to be treated at a nor facility and
air facility they would have to get a
certificate the same way that they would
to bring a a body to a Crematory it's
process
thank you um well like I said I I just I
literally just bumped into this friend
of mine who I know works at the Farm
Bureau so I asked him and uh he said he
would look into it he he off the top of
his head he wasn't totally familiar with
their uh statutes and so forth and rules
but he was going to look into it uh I
can give you his contact information and
yeah
yeah okay
so yeah and you know like I said I just
happened literally bumped into him in
the hall and just said well hey do you
that
one of the one of the things that uh
comes to my mind also I think uh members
of the committee were all shocked uh
when you talked about um um the large
amount of product that's produced as
compared to
Cremation uh you know a truck bed full
as compared to a six or seven uh pound
canister of Ashes uh and uh it was
suggested uh yeah the the family may
want a little portion of that but I
think we need to talk about or figure
out what could be done to dispose of the
rest of that that properly uh if the
family doesn't want to claim it or even
if they only want a small amount yeah
which I would
think
yeah you just said some people will take
a small
where but again she that they test it
they're required to test it by
their
no right you're GNA keep talking I think
you but the point is no I understand
we're being recorded only you're
not and well the other difference um
like life Forest is a little different
from a cemetery if they were to take um
the soil from natural organic reduction
it's not as though they're burying a
person because at at this point the soil
is soil there's really no it's not human
remains
anymore and we did try to
address the ways that the soil might be
um distributed or
dispersed in the cemetery chapter and
likewise it's it's pretty common that
people accept that um Ash is from
cremation people can do whatever they
want with them there's no regulation at
all we did try to Define what was a
scattering Garden or a memorial for
Forest if someone was setting up a place
specifically to accept those things if
they were going to say yes we're going
to take your ashes here and put them in
a place with a marker for the
person then then they are acting more
like a
cemetery right but if they are taking
the ashes or the no soil with no marker
whatsoever then they're just taking this
material
um and and using it
to help regenerate a forest but they're
not acting as is a
cemetery so that's kind of the the
difference there but we did try to
address that and I I agree that maybe we
could work on that I mean I believe that
was what I believe that was why the arch
dasis objected because they said that
you're not treating The Remains with
proper respect even if they have
been combined with other elements and
matured into soil it's
still it's still part of a person I
don't
think if you said okay we're going to
use the the the the soil that the
families don't want and build a BM in
front of our our facility you wouldn't
get much support for it I think people
want to know that even if it's been
degraded and processed it's still
treated with
respect absolutely I think that it's
true um one of the one of the things
that I noted uh in the piece that you
sent us I forget I don't know if it was
last night or this morning um item
three um well it's like the second item
three um says NE
nhdes has stated they would not require
any special regulations for no soil but
then further down under
five um you state that um easement from
future developments should follow best
practices as defined by the Department
of Environmental Services so there's a
little conflict there that needs to be
ironed
out that was a reference to an easement
though to like protection of the land
yeah yeah I think the latter was the
intention was to have remains go
someplace where it would be in
perpetuity a park or a a reserved place
not suddenly built into houses in 10
years so that was the intention there
different from Dees regulating the
actual product or
soil so I meeting the I would also yes
well I I just want to say um I would
urge you folks to um reach out to the
funeral directors uh group and uh take
input from them and I'm I'm asking if
you would care to um have any input into
have okay yeah all right yes okay yes
thank you would you yes yes please come
thank
you because that that was one of the
concerns also is whether or not um the
community cemeteries would have to uh
like do special ordinances or something
to allow this uh in their facilities
right and for the record yeah my name is
Mike horn I'm uh uh Secretary treasur of
the New Hampshire Cemetery Association
which have about 120 members and
represent you know 40 40 associ and
towns and um we became aware of this
back in mid January and couldn't make
the hearing before um and we had a board
meeting this morning and I said I'll be
in conquered I'll come here to speak and
and we're hoping to to meet with the
representatives and have them come to
our April meeting to speak to the
cemeterian of which we'll have probably
70 70 75 people there and um you know to
learn more about what's being proposed
and and you know hopefully we can help
craft the the language and and and make
it something that everybody can agree
with you know we weren't looking so much
at the natural organic reduction there
was even some concern on getting more
definitions in the state rsas about
green burials and other stuff of which
we you know we struggle with but uh we
just wanted to have have our input
considered and uh and and they did we
did one of the representatives was
connected to our vice president but they
didn't have time to to connect and
collaborate before this hearing so okay
thank you very much for coming I I would
urge you to exchange information with
representative
you
it would not be enacted this year but
what we would do is if you come back to
us with something that we feel is
workable we would recommend it for
bium I'm I'm a first term rep so I don't
understand understand the process very
well but would we meet again with the
committee as or do we just to be honest
it's up to the committee and some
committees don't take it very seriously
but Edna has the bad habit of actually
working on most of our inter study okay
so we would expect to meet with the
interested parties to answer some of the
questions and resolve some of the
hanging issues okay so we would do our
homework and come back with some new
ideas and bring everyone to the table
for a session yes if we choose to have
another subcommittee meeting uh it would
be broadcast to you as this notice was
sent to you as sponsors and we would
probably notify the interested parties
as well to come to see what kind of
compromise you may have reached okay and
then and then eventually uh the full
committee will have to vote on whether
or not we recommend uh future
legislation okay so you have like two
bites of the Apple coming still okay
thank
you okay I a Christian
minister
problem
so I'm a Christian minister and um so I
just want to be fair and let you know I
I do have a problem with this bill we
can say you know you put a body in it
comes out that this is not human marins
it is so I do have a problem with the
bill I'm just being honest so um take
that in cons
well
right we're talking this is the subc
community meeting for House Bill
1486 which talks about proxy carbon
pricing and state procurement so I think
what we are the reason why we we called
this subcommittee meeting was because
frankly the commit the
hearing had a lot of extra stuff in it
which made it very confusing so I'm
hoping you can tell us what the bill is
about and what um what it
means well what it's about what you
would you like the state to do and what
would it do you know how would it be
effective I guess that's what we need to
know all right thank you very much Madam
chair and uh I for the record and I'm
Nick Gera um State Rep from Kean
district one uh chesher one so the idea
behind this bill is to make purchasing
to have the state make purchasing
decisions that are in the best interest
of taxpayers and also keeps in mind in
this case the pricing of carbon as a
part of the formula that the state uses
so I appreciate apprciate the
opportunity to talk to the subcommittee
because I think the discussion and and
the the original hearing got off topic
uh into much larger questions about
carbon pricing in general and carbon
taxes and consumer behavior um I think
good questions were asked there about
you know those kind larger issues but
this bill is specifically about State
purchasing decisions it's not about
carbon tax it's not about trying to
influence consumer Behavior across the
state or the region or any of those
things it's saying that looking at the
energy landscape right now we see that
Canada has adopted a carbon pricing
model the European Union has adopted a
carbon pricing model right that is going
to eventually end up somehow working
into our system because these are
enormous trading partners for the United
States and so we we get put at an
economic
disadvantage when we're working with in
a different system than they are we're
going to be paying carbon taxes from
Canada and the European Union there will
be uh penalties in all likelihood
applied to American companies exporting
right so we're going to have to somehow
move in the direction of a carbon model
right so what this bill does is says
that let's use a proxy price right we
don't have a system right now and it's
not proposing any carbon tax or anything
it's saying let's look at the market
let's look at what the Canada and the
European Union are doing and let's use a
proxy
price eventually we're going to have to
go in this direction let's use that when
we make a decision if we are renovating
a state building if we're building a new
facility if we're buying vehicles for
transportation let's use that proxy
price as we calculate how much it's
going to cost to run this thing over the
course of its lifetime right so if
you're installing a new HVAC system
either in a renovated building or in a
new building right we price these things
how much is it going to cost us to
operate this thing over the lifetime of
that
system this puts a this proxy carbon
price in the mix right so if we say at
this point in time we have system a a
traditional kind of heating
system how much is it going to cost to
operate that thing for 30 years right if
in 30 years or well before that we have
a prox we have an actual carbon price we
have to factor that in it's going to be
part of the cost of operating that
system
right let's not use the you know
eventually we're going to have that
basically what we're doing but just s
having I view this as sort of like a
trial run it's an
experiment to see how this would affect
our decision
making is that right yes so thank you
very much for asking that question so
the bill as it's written would require
the department of administrative
services to factor it in in what I have
uh thought about and I'd be willing to
you know I'd be happy to talk to you all
about is the idea that through an
amendment we could change the bill
exactly as you suggest to say that it is
not a binding part of the
formula but that when we make these
decisions they're calculated and they're
recorded and then over five years over
10 years from now or after the the
enactment of the legislation we can look
at that history and we can say
okay what was the better decision and if
it turns out that this model was not
would not have saved taxpayers money
then we have the evidence we need right
and if somebody comes forward with a
similar bill you say no because we have
this evidence that it doesn't work right
so I appreciate that and and I'm
absolutely amendable uh so to speak to
an amendment that would make it
non-binding and simply have it be
reported as a part of the
process Okay so I think that's helpful
the other issue is how how much of an
effort does it take for
our the fact that the
Dr I mean Department Das Dr geez the Das
is not here to testify against it leads
me to believe that they're sort of they
have no opinion of it because they
certainly are here when they're against
something so how um how much of an
effort is inv involves is it it's not
for every single thing that we buy it's
only for things that are related to
energy is that right yes thank you very
much and I appreciate uh you pointing
out that you know if the department of
administrative Services I assume if this
was a mountain to lift uh they would
come and they would say you know we
can't do this the effective date is
January 1st right of 2025 so again if
this was a concern that they had that
they couldn't do it in time I assume
that somebody from that department would
be here telling us either you know we
need longer or we can't do it so um I I
appreciate that question and uh
I it is specific to purchases on uh
equipment including say automobiles that
consume carbon right so it it's not on
everything you know when you're building
a new structure for example it is
specific for example to the an HVAC
system as opposed to you know all of the
other bidding that has to be done on on
the various kind of subcontracts so yes
carbon thank you
um my my concern is
a what I what I'll term as a creeping
Elegance in the direction of
electrification we've we have seen
hard evidence that across the state at
different points there have been efforts
to um and we're talking at at the
consumer level and I know this this bill
is right now not trying to attack
consumer issues but but to me it's it's
incremental this is
incremental uh efforts to get there at
some point
um that through the planning board
process there have been efforts AC in
different parts of the state and and
we've seen evidence mostly along the
western part of the state close to the
Vermont
border uh where planning boards have
been uh encouraged or told not to
approve any any plans that didn't in
that didn't require
electrification of utilities you can't
you know new new homes that are about to
be
approved can't be approved with furnaces
that use oil or or gas they have to use
heat pumps electric heat pumps and and
so uh and we had to we've had to step in
and say no uh the the consumer needs to
be able to be in charge of making their
own decisions about things like that and
we and the the government shouldn't be
mandating that uh so my concern is that
that that while that specific example
doesn't apply really to this bill it's
it's this incrementalism or or looking
to push in that direction so that at
some point in time and say well it's now
time to flip the switch no pun intended
but flip the switch to say we're going
to now require what we were just before
watching or looking at are evaluating
now it's a
requirement uh to say You must now when
you buy a heating system for the state
the new parking garage across the street
is going to have to use electric heat
pumps will not be allowed to to use uh
propane heaters or U natural gas heaters
or whatever um and and that's what
that's what I'm concerned about is how
how do how do we is there are there any
ways to put safeguards in so that we
this doesn't all of a sudden there be
like a giant blob that devours us and we
we turn around one day five years from
now and say how do we get here I said
well uh it's everything has to be
electric I mean and using myself and and
please allow me
I'm being diverting a little bit here no
go ahead couple of days ago with with
this heavy snowstorm we had we lost in
London der where I'm from we've a
terrible uh experience with osaurus who
lose power all the time and I happen to
live on a culdesac which means you're
going to get the power last
back um but we lose power all the time
so to mitigate that uh because I did a
lot of business travel and when I was
gone I didn't want my wife out there
trying to pour gas lean into a oh come
on a small generator a small
generator uh and she and she was too
afraid anyway she refused to do it so uh
by herself right so so I went out and
invested $22,000 into a a
propane uh generator a whole house
generator so when the power goes out it
comes back on in about 10 seconds and
she's she's got power and she's not in
the dark and in the cold
that's a that's an option as a homeowner
that I want it's an option if I were to
translate that as a as a uh a
community uh a police station I want a
diesel generator running when the power
goes out to the to to power the the
police station not just an an electric
uh line to the to the to the electric
company that's gone out anyway because
there's no power now uh or the fire
station they also have de diesel
generators to fire up and and now it's a
safety issue so what I'm concerned about
is this
electrification but it it
doesn't I'm thinking about the consumer
side of it we're not we're not in this
bill talking consumer but we are talking
about large purchases of of government
agencies and a police station is a
government
agency
it's state right but you know once we
require it for the State Police how long
will it be before it migrates to the
Community Police or the from the or to
the community fire station so so I I
just think we're on a we talked slippery
slope earlier everybody knows how I feel
about that word right so we won't go
there but anyway um I I just think we we
have to be very careful we don't TI eles
into nuts and and end up like California
is now with rolling blackouts and brown
outs and so forth because they're so
overcommitted to electrification and
even even in large Power Systems like
Community Power Systems and so forth so
we we've got I would think we need some
protection and I don't know if it's a
study or do some
analysis or uh and I I'm not a big fan
of studies because I'm on a I'm on on
the the commission on to get rid of all
these study studies commissions that we
have but anyway this this to me if you
want to go down this path it needs a lot
more thought and a lot more analysis so
we don't back ourselves into the corner
where we're we're we're now stuck and
can't and can't use our resources our
our energy resources to help us navigate
through emergency periods and and so
forth you I just want I
just so I I wanted to make sure that
with the disc with the amendment that
representative gerana is
proposing it
wouldn't what we would do is exactly I
think what you're trying to do is we're
we're only Gathering data on the state
level to see if this at all even works
so we're not going to make any decisions
based on it or we're not going to um
yeah we're not going to you know decide
anything on it it's really just a matter
of gathering data to see if at all if
this is something
that would be beneficial long term and
maybe it won't be but rather than
mandating that we do something that we
don't know anything about what we're
doing is we're in a way creating an
experiment which I'm a big experiment
person myself so let's experiment let's
gather the data and then determine where
we are I I would just like to know for
example if we were doing this as an
experiment how much time do we need to
gather enough data to know whether what
the effect of this would
be U thank you uh and I'd also like if I
may to address another part of
Representative Dolan's concerns in terms
of kind of what is the um kind of safety
involved here right so that we don't go
down this slippery slope and and I would
say that in this bill the difference
between what you see in California for
example or some of the things that I
think that you're concerned about is
that the target the specific Target
underlying legislation like that is the
reduction in greenhouse gases the Target
in this bill is what is going to save
taxpayers money right so the the
fundamental underlying principle is not
we're going to purchase the things that
will have the lowest the least carbon
footprint I think that's the kind of
thing that you're concerned about and we
could disagree about that but this bill
does do that this bill says that the
metric that we're concerned with is
saving taxpayer money and I think if
that's the metric if that's the
fundamental underlying principle um I I
I think that should address some of the
concerns that you have because as you
said it's not we're going to buy this
thing just because it has a smaller
footprint right we're going to do it
ideally because it's going to cost
taxpayers less so I hope that speaks to
some of your concerns about uh how this
legislation fits into the larger
patterns that you're concerned about I
like the language about saving taxpayer
money but I
think I think the evidence before us is
that this is going to cost the taxpayers
more money and you have to look at
longterm versus short term in the short
term if we could get
a185 uh fuel that would be saving us
money as opposed to uh
$5 a gallon but $5 a gallon may be what
the long-term cost is in terms of you
know the carbon footprint uh type
analysis so so we really need
to bring into the discussion short-term
costs long-term costs uh short-term
costs I think I think by
maximizing uh
energy um availability is the this is
the the tax saving formula in the short
term I think a case can be made that if
we don't pay attention to the
environment that it's is there going to
be a long-term cost that it's going to
cost us more in the long term but but we
that we that needs to enter into the
discussion so people understand that
we're going to walk away from
a185 uh fuel cost and we're going to go
to a $5 fuel cost because 10 years from
now we're all going to be paying
$20 I hear what you're saying
representative but that's not to my
understanding that's not how the
department of administrative Services
determines how they're going to purchase
equipment and that's what this is about
so I hear what you're saying and that
this became part of that larger
discussion in the committee right and
that's an important discussion to have
and it's very complex for all the
reasons that you indicate that's not
what this is about and the department of
administrative Service as I said to my
understanding does not use any of those
things when it determines what kinds of
equipment to buy the question is how how
do we how do we um do a test or an
analysis that's not
open-ended and I think the
representative groda Madam chair
referred to that so two things I would
say one I'm I'm happy to I've asked OS
for some language they haven't been able
to get back to me that I would share
with you all that again would make it
non-binding so in that case we're
Gathering data and then um you know if
if we want to talk about what kind of
time period we're looking at
I mean to say that it's open-ended I I
don't necessarily think is a bad thing
because it would require further
legislation to change it into something
that was generally binding right so if
there's no further legislation and we're
just Gathering data for five or 10 years
whatever we have five or 10 years worth
of data to look back at and again if
someone comes before the committee with
a bill that wants to make it binding we
then can say well we we now have say a
decade's worth of data so I I personally
don't see any need to put into the
legislation a Sunset date date for this
because it's not going to enact anything
it's not going to make it binding after
a certain period of time so I don't
personally see that as as being
necessary but I'm we typically don't
keep things running forever we typically
have a sunset
time okay and so whatever the committee
thinks is reasonable I would certainly
be happy to have that as part of an
amendment oh I'm sorry I didn't mean to
step on you that's
okay guess I need
this um I've lived in a house with heat
pumps and they're fine but they use
electricity and electricity is going to
put whatever in the in the air plus the
cost of electricity is going to go up so
we're not gaining
anything by using something like a heat
pump um we're going to still end up Uh
something's got I mean granted maybe
they'll put solar panels or they'll have
wind or something to generate the
electricity but until we get to that
point we're a long way from
it those aren't
practical just for pollution purposes
well what I would say I I appreciate
that and that came up in the in the
Committee hearing too in terms of a lot
of the things we power through
electricity right you know 50% I believe
of our of our electricity is is
generated on fossil fuels and that would
be calculated into the the price so
again in this case if we were talking
about a non-binding price we're just
trying to gather data that we can use
over time if the state is looking at
different ways to heat a building and
they looked at a heat pump they would
have to look at the carbon price
attached to electrification and then you
would just look at again what is the
cost efficient
decision yeah yeah I I don't know maybe
insulating the house more would help or
something on on that order new window so
your air doesn't come in but whatever
heat pump is perfectly fine it has good
heat no problem
um I don't know that Jackie agrees with
that statement but no no I do I do I
just that I feel like we're talking
about we're not talking about existing
things because we're talking
about things that the state would would
purchase that require energy and they
can purchase whatever they want all
we're doing is going to be creating a
database that says yes you know if they
had if this if this had been considered
this would be the cost and maybe we're
going to find out that that that system
let's just let's just say for
example you buy a car that runs on uh
gasoline they buy a car runs on
diesel and and then in the in the non
non-mandated uh column they have a car
that that's a hybrid let's just let's
just use those examples okay so how much
is the car that runs on gas cost how
much is the gas the car that runs on div
cost how much is the hybrid cost right
now long term if you were to look at the
you know the price of gas is the same or
the price of
diesel you know they have to look at the
that which car was the most effective
purchase at the
time right so that and so basically
nobody mandated the town to buy the
diesel car but had they bought the car
would that number be lower long term
than the diesel car or the gas car and
that be you can you can substitute a gas
thing gas car diesel car hybrid car for
whatever it could be a heat back system
one with heat pumps one without heat
pumps and one with you know I have no
idea what so you know
or um I'm trying to think of something
else that runs on uh those those heating
systems that run stuff on they run pipes
under the ground radi yeah radiation not
radi it's you know I'm sure you know
what it's called where heat no it's you
you send the oh Thermo Thermo when they
run something down to the ground yeah
they run
ital geothermal yeah that's another one
right so is that kind of thing and we
and basically what we're saying is in
the decisions that the
state makes when they're buying
something we want them to run this
experiment based on what an alternative
it could be that in the they decide to
buy the hybrid car the gas the gas
car and they put the diesel car in the
it doesn't matter what they put in there
right no that's right I mean it's how
they designed the experiment that we're
not going to tell them how to do that no
all we want them to do is consider this
experiment so that they can cons collect
data Che well isn't the the purpose of
it to try to figure out what the carbon
footprint is no afterwards no no no and
and that's why I was saying I I hope
that would address some of your concerns
because the bottom line is cost cost
cost is is the driver here so another
example trying to convert Co carbon
footprint into cost our and I I like the
idea of of uh Madam
chair's example because our argument our
bet if you will is that over the long
term reducing our carbon footprint is
going to save money right now that's
debatable but that's but that but that's
not what this bill does right so that we
would especially if we amend it so that
it is is gathering data so again 10
years from now you and I could sit here
and we could look at that 10 years worth
of data and one of us could say to the
other one C I was
right all right so so what's the what's
the calendar look like well how long are
we going to run the experiment yeah well
I don't think we should run it for in
five years because I don't think that
we're going to gather any data that's
meaningful because first of all how many
things do the state Buy number one
number two how long do these things last
know if it's a vehicle they last for a
long time but the first five years of a
vehicle they're pretty efficient and
they they're you know they're not
they're not falling apart so I think
five years is a good
number I mean that's what would the
legislation look like though for for a
fiveyear experiment they're going to put
it in he's going to put it in in an
amendment and we're going to look at and
it would be so it there would be a
sunset Clause be a study for five years
well I I think what we would do because
we can't bind a future legislature right
so we would Sunset it and then in that
last year uh if if somebody wanted it to
continue then they probably would submit
a bill maybe me uh for a study committee
based and then you could use data that
you would gather as the foundation of a
sub as as a study committee uh but but
what I'm suggesting is as as The Madam
chair pointed out is that uh I we can
put a sunset clause in and then we have
this as something that the state
calculates but does not use as a part of
its decision making what agcy would do
this do you think Department of
administrative Services
Charlie and I think the other point is
you know and I I I like uh Madam chair's
example the other one I was thinking of
is if you were to buy an HVAC system or
a car either way right if you were to
kind of do your own experiment and say
okay well I'm I'm I'm trying to decide
between these two right well you have to
choose one let's say you choose one but
you also kind of keep the records well
what if I had bought that other heating
system right and then you can compare
five 10 years out five years out in this
case right you can look back and either
feel really good because you made the
right decision or feel bad because you
think man I'm losing money but so it
would be like that right we're Mak
making a a purchasing decision using the
same metrics we currently use and
keeping the you know the carbon proxy
price as a data point that just for
informational purposes so that as you
said down the line perhaps there's a
study committee that then can do what
the original bill here intended to do
but we would have data to base that on
now would we think that Edna would be
the monitoring
come
me well I think members of they'd have
to well we wouldn't have a study
committee what we would have to do is
after the two-year period if and we
renewed it Das I'll speak to to um we
wouldn't be this would be something that
Das would could report to our committee
after they've collected the data yes
they would report it to us because then
we could say we together the study
committee because the reason why we are
the reason why this bill is before us
and not before science technology and
energy is because it involves
Das right and because it involves Das
they would be the ones who could come to
us and say we did the study committee
and this is what we found right yeah I I
would be in favor of of keeping it in
Edna
okay okay good yes so that we don't lose
track of it right right okay I think
that's good especially since this is a
yeah
okay so I don't think that do we agree
that we want um representative ger to go
to OS and and draft this amendment and
then do we want to look at it and meet
again or yes okay so we're going to do
that
um we're meeting Friday morning but
that's probably to that's a that
different uh that's that's different
that's
on is it possible to meet can you have
see if you can get the amendment by
Wednesday morning by thir oh no yeah get
try to get it to us by
Thursday right because we have a house
session on Thursday and then we have an
exec
executive session that
afternoon so we could meet before the
executive
session and let's try to do that I won't
be I won't be here Thursday afternoon
you
won't
okay Nick you're g go get any
Amendment yes and I'll have to ask them
to add a 5year Sunset date that wasn't
part of the original
so doesn't take very long yeah that's
that's the easy part and the report to
provide the report to us to our commit
yeah
that attendance could be a problem
because I would be missing and you'd be
adding someone new ma Matthew would be
added he would have the benefit of this
discussion no I know okay so let me um
but I can meet
Friday okay well
Friday mid Friday
and I did also based on uh chairwoman
Maguire's suggestion I asked OSS to tell
me what kind of uh rule writing
empowerment language is required uh I'm
not you know my understanding was that
if we instructed the department to do
this that they would then therefore
simply have to write the rules about how
they do it uh the chairwoman said that
uh
you she believed that rule writing
empowerment was required I have asked
OSS to uh tell me if that has to be a
part of the bill and if it does that
will also be part of the
amendment okay so let's do this I don't
think that this is an early bill but
that's okay so how about next week we're
meeting
again
um so let's try let's make it we have
EXA session at 10 o'clock on Wednesday
that's on the 7th yeah okay so let's
meet on the 6 at 3:00 or after our
committee okay okay Tuesday the 6th at
3:00 we'll meet again and you'll bring
the
amendment this house bill
1486 3 o'clock you said Madam chair yep
and I don't know where it's going to be
because they could be here again we
won't have our regular say class our
almost our regular we won't have our
um Regular committee room so we might be
here I don't know but look for the look
forward in the calendar okay now we do
have a a a committee meeting on
Wednesday the 7th we also have one on
the six oh we do yeah I I didn't add my
calendar yet yeah we have a he
six
so
um okay this was very helpful yes it was
yes thank you so much well I appreciate
you all taking the time at the end of a
long day to meet with me to talk about
the bill well that's what we do right we
all do that for each
other okay I'm just looking at the
calendar just to make sure that I'm not
a Yeah
Tuesday
committee tomorrow tomorrow yes yes I'm
talking about next Tuesday okay for some
reason I didn't have anything on next
Tuesday but no we don't it's not in the
calendar for next week either we do have
one for
calendar so let me talk to to Carol
because we should be here next Tuesday
you know what let's just
everybody I'm going to I'll schedule
something for either next Tuesday or
Wednesday depending on what day we're
here okay okay y that sounds good okay
great thanks so much and subcommittee
meeting is over we
yes
that